[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
within the Tempest the best have come to
test their skills and brave the storm
oh my goodness the wheels the wheels
have come out that could be the match
for some this is familiar ground oh my
goodness Knight d8 whoa
oh my God what a tactic
this is insane oh look at Fabby
exhausting every last resource the
battles will be electricity
the moves will be fast it's game over
it's winning oh my God yes it is he's
gonna make a queen the stakes will be
high he just grabs his head he can't
believe it he just gave away the pawn
the 2022 speed Chess Championship is now
fasten your speed belts my friends we're
in for a wild ride
didn't last long because we have yet
another epic match for you today less
than 24 hours after the previous one
concluded
that's the beauty of the SCC it all
happens fast and there is a lot at stake
in each and every match this may be the
fourth and last quarter final here in
the 2022 SCC but there is a lot of prize
money to be won the total pot is one
hundred thousand dollars but here in the
quarter Files The Winner Takes four
thousand plus a split of an additional
four thousand dollars based on win
percentage and of course perhaps most
importantly to these hungry players
Veterans of the SEC they move on to the
semi-finals where Magnus Carlson awaits
Dania he spoke yesterday about this
matchup he said that well he wants some
revenge against Maxime and he also he
said that Wesley has been playing his
best perhaps Magnus is absolutely a man
on a mission let's be clear about one
thing if Magnus plays the way he did
yesterday not Wesley so not Daenerys
Targaryen not God himself will be able
to stop him from advancing and winning
the finals of the SEC so the other
players are basically hoping that he
doesn't display the same form and when
Wesley so is one of those players who
definitely has a shot against Magnus
when he's playing let's let's say with
his standard form when Wesley is
Unstoppable he's reminiscent of the
Magnus that we saw yesterday we saw that
kind of Wesley at the cgc Right Wesley
is the first chess.com Global
Championship but the winner of this
match faces off against Magnus Carlson
Magnus Carlsen so dominant yesterday
22-4 he didn't lose a single game
against his former Challenger for the
world chess champion title in Fabiano
caruana so Dania you know this bracket
it's down to five players remaining the
three who are already entrenched in the
semi-finals and then one player from
today's match will it be Wesley will be
Maxine will work their way through to
play in the semi-final matchup against
Magnus Carlson yeah I don't know what
what movie scene or video game scene
this reminds me of Magnus Carlson kind
of waiting the Shadows so you gotta
defeat one boss and then you've got
another boss but right now MBL and so
obvious obviously focused on trying to
beat each other but but this bracket is
just amazing I mean literally every one
of these matches has had its unique
character its unique pathway the unique
Narrative of the match it's been amazing
to cover the SEC thus far and hey we got
more good stuff coming your way very
shortly
we certainly do in Wesley and Maxime
they ventured into the quarterfinals
through different opponents but now that
we're here it is two players who are
very familiar with each other Wesley has
a lifetime lead against Maxine Buster
legrav but Dania sometimes the past is
the past and the future holds a
different story Maxine is the world
Blitz Champion the reigning one which
for some reason people often forget I
mean mvl isn't usually featured in the
same conversation of of Blitz Legends
and yet he is a blitz Legend and he
always has been and it's not even
surprising when you think about his
playing style in classical that he's
amazing at Blitz I mean the guy plays
fast he's incredibly booked up in the
opening so he's got all of the classical
characteristics of a blitz Legend he
should be featured on the same pedestal
that we put Wesley so but with that
being said Wesley did win uh their last
SCC meeting in 2019 it was an incredibly
close Affair though as you can see and
Wesley so you know perennial finalist in
this format when Magnus Carlson is not
competing in fact Wesley has only ever
lost to Magnus or Hikaru in this event
and Maxima Shirley Grove he did in fact
beat Magnus Carlson a few years back so
that is something we'll keep in mind and
we should remind everybody of the format
because I know a day isn't that long of
a period of time in between matches but
some people forget that this is a 16
player knockout the players play in
three different time controls and if it
a tie when the timer finally runs out we
get four games of bullet chess one
minute plus one second increment and if
that is still tied we get to Armageddon
with bidding everyone's Favorite Time
control where it all is on the line the
excitement is palpable but Dania I think
the players they would like to knock
each other out in regulation today they
would indeed and it's an amazing time
controlled super elegant 90 60 30. it's
easy to remember and it features lots of
different types of chests and really the
match can be decided in any one of the
three time controls which I think is
really encapsulates what a format should
be an amazing performance in any one of
these segments can give you the push
that you need to get the decisive lead
but you cannot relax in the other
segments conversely you can also mount a
comeback in any of these segments
including the bullet segment and that's
been really the sub narrative Robert of
the SEC thus far how many bullet
comebacks have we seen two points down
three points down and we've seen all
sorts of players really shine through in
the bullet when we didn't really expect
them to but in this case we expect both
players to shine in the bullet that's
for sure that is for sure neither these
players needed to worry about the bullet
because they were well ahead in their
matches they separate themselves from
their quarter excuse me first round
opponents we are now in the last
quarterfinal matchup and well smarter
chess predictions this is always a good
time for us Dania we love to call out
smarter chess but in this one he has
Maxine vasilagrav the 11th seed as a 64
favorite you know win probability much
higher than his opponent of Wesley so
and a slight favorite in the shorter
time patrols is mvl according to smarter
chess this might be the first smarter
chess prediction that I'm like genuinely
surprised by the other is I've had to
begrudgingly admit I would have probably
put a similar percentage but 64 for mvl
given Wesley so's recent form and given
his consistency and stability that's an
incredibly bold prediction smarter chest
so this is one that might not age very
well but it's interesting that he thinks
there's gonna be a time the five plus
one and the bullet is really going to be
where and mvl pulls through I mean the
bullet is always a total Wild Card
though Robert that we know yeah that one
is up for grabs but the community also
got involved it's not just smarter chess
making predictions the community
actually said that Wesley so is a 70
favorite so you're at odds of smart
chess just like we typically are but
it's interesting to note that many more
people pick Wesley so perhaps because
the seating perhaps it's because of his
recent win in a magnificent win that was
at the global Championship but either
way heavy favorite is Wesley according
to the people who filled out brackets
yeah and thank you to everybody who did
fill out a bracket this is like the
scene in Who Wants To Be A Millionaire I
don't know if Chad is still familiar
with that game I used to watch it very
regularly but you'd use the ask the
audience help and the audience would
shout the answer is D then you'd call a
friend and the friend would say I'm 100
sure the answer is B so you don't know
which one to go for the community
prediction or smarter chess I'm going to
withhold as the unbiased commentator
we'll we'll see there's only one way to
find out
there is indeed and I'm also interested
to note that not many people predicted
this matchup and I believe that's
because Maxime was the 11th seed yonda
palmashi was the higher seed the six
seed in that matchup so probably people
picked John based on his recent
successes in the rapid Chess
Championship of course he is the
Challenger to the World Chess
Championship of play against dingley
Wren I mean yonda palm tree kind of
winning events left and right so I
understand that but not many people
remembering Maxine Bossier legrav has
taken a bit of a Hiatus as it has felt
like but he is the reigning world Blitz
champion and he has defeated Magnus
Carlson in this format so I believe
Dania that Maxime is a bit
underestimated by the people but maybe
perhaps a little bit overestimated by
smarter chess yeah I think you I mean
personally I would I would say this is
an absolute 50 50 match this is this can
go either way and you can make a strong
case for the player who's got better
form in this match to win but mvl Hiatus
has lasted even maybe two years maybe
three years really since the start of
covet he didn't participate as much in
those online events and I think for that
reason he was kind of thrown under the
bus by a lot of players I mean two years
is not that long of a time you don't
forget how the pieces move uh in that
amount of time as we see mvl there nice
cozy little office I don't know where he
went but I'm not going to speculate on
that probably to get snacks because
that's generally what he's munching on
all throughout the match he really is
and he does have a winning record
throughout the SEC I mean this is his
sixth appearance his eight match wins
six losses and he is the reigning world
Blitz chess chain as we have noted so
experience does pay off but for maxim
he's facing off another veteran of this
event that's not going to be easy and we
just saw Maxime in his room we're
getting word that there's a heavy
snowstorm in Wesley so's area so he had
to rent out a room in the local library
hopefully the internet is stable there
and of course all of West these fans he
has so many of them especially after his
win at the cgc where he was so humble
and grateful for everybody all the staff
members who he said propelled him the
victory but Wesley there in the local
library hopefully he has good internet
connection
yeah libraries generally do have good
internet connections some of the most
stable of any public institution in my
experience
but anything can happen in a snowstorm
what a big surprise a snowstorm in
Minnesota Robert I mean who would have
thought in December
I think I think I think it's time to
move to you know Charlotte or New York
that's right I'm enjoying my 55 degree
day here well considering I'm not even
in New York right now I think that's a
familiar background behind me I was
gonna say I I kind of recognized that
with this Anonymous individual who
commentated with yesterday I already
forgot his name he wasn't very memorable
um it was honestly kind of kind of bad
commentary to be totally honest so
well I'll make sure to pass on that
message considering I'm staying with
that very lad but here we see that you
know there are two players who are
locked in will Maxime be able to
replicate some of his former success
like when he defeated uh Magus Carlson
two years ago and made it to the final
well Wesley so make it through and he
has only lost to Hikaru Nakamura and
Magnus Carlson so that is interesting to
note will Maxime be that surprise and we
just keep talking about Magnus Carlson I
as a spectator cannot get over what I
witnessed yesterday you had the call you
were busy working hard I was just
chilling legs up saying how is Magnus
Carlson doing this so Donna you had that
call now that a day has gone by I mean
what kind of explanations can you
possibly have what insights do you feel
you've gleaned how are you feeling now
that some time has passed between that
Demolition and today and the thing of
these kinds of performances that we saw
yesterday and you can draw parallels
really to any sport there have been
performances like this across basketball
football so whatever sport you want to
name you can name an equivalent
performance like that and when it's
going on you you don't believe until the
very last second that it's actually
going to happen at first you don't
really believe it's going to be a
blowout right it's just a matter of time
before carwana starts coming back then
when they reach the bullet you don't
believe that he's going to go lossless I
mean who would go 30 minutes of bullet
against Corona without a single loss
when there's five minutes left in the
match you're like okay Fabby is going to
win one of the last two games he's going
to win the last game and then when he
doesn't everybody just kind of emits a
breath and it's a crazy feeling it was
one of the greatest performances in
terms of level of play Robert it was
definitely probably top three Blitz
performances of all time I mean I'm sure
the measurements can be made but I think
his level of play uh was comparable to
that of probably a classical Grandmaster
in that match which is absurd
yeah no that is a really well stated uh
rationale there and I feel like as a
spectator I just felt the power of
Magnus Carlson because we all remember
their world championship match between
Magnus and Fabi it was neck and neck
they were locked they could not separate
over the 12 classical games then Magnus
was able to win in the shorter time
controls but these are long time foes
and then you could say what rivalry
right that's what Magnus Carlson he was
putting his foot down on that saying
this isn't a rivalry I am the dominant
force in the Chess World it doesn't
matter if I have this fancy world
championship title to my name I am still
the best player the number one rated
player in the world and I'm gonna show
off my might here in the SEC and well
two players who would like to take down
Magnus in the near future Wesley so
Maxine vashilagrove they're set up
they're about ready to start their first
game we have some random Blitz game
finish on the screen in front of you and
chat got involved they predicted Maxime
to be the winner of the five plus one
segment it's a close kind of prediction
there 53-47 Donna do you see Maxime as
the favorite slightly in the longest
time for sure do you disagree with chat
I don't really agree with chat I I again
I think all three time controls are
complete 50 50. like it's it's honestly
the player has the better form is going
to win this match
and I I mean Wesley has been so sharp in
the opening but he plays in Italian with
white I mean I don't think anybody is
the favorite against him obviously mdl
is not an E5 player and that's actually
something new because the last three or
four opponents that Wesley has faced in
the cgc and the SEC I feel like he's
gotten a whole lot of E4 E5 so big
question how is Wesley going to adapt to
mvl's opening repertoire well let's find
out because the games have kicked off
and you ask and Maxine answered with a
sicilian so no E4 E5 business here Dania
we're getting a night or with Knight to
G4 will Wesley oh Bishop C1 I was gonna
say will he play Bishop G5 there it is
he's just teasing his opponent a little
bit yeah maybe you think we're gonna
make a repetition but not so fast so
Daniel what do you make of this opening
yeah this Knight G4 line has been around
for a while it's been around since
really the 90s and the age of Gary
Kasparov and it's had some ups and downs
it's really overshadowed in popularity
Robert by E5 and E6 and mvl is really to
my knowledge one of the only top Grand
Masters who still plays it which is
always exciting you're kind of sinking
down with the ship uh but obviously it's
it's a really as good of a line as as
any other night or variation but it
leads to some very unique structures you
don't get a Pawn on G5 like this in the
night or in any other line
yeah and look at this H4 played by
Wesley so striking at the pony G5 that
is overextended you'd prefer not to have
your king side in shambles but already
it's an open position in front of the
black king side so will that King 98
Dania stay in the center will it Venture
on over to G8 and castle that looks very
dangerous so I believe that Maxine will
keep that King in the center for the
time being and speaking of time Wesley
well ahead in the clock in game one here
I already don't love Maxim's position
here I mean what does he have to show
for the damage that Wesley just
inflicted on the king side and its
long-term damage mvl's got to whip up
some Queen side counter play which he's
trying to do
but the email bar is having none of it
maybe just Knight D4 and the F5 Square
looks pretty juicy as well love that and
there's almost a tactic here Donya
Knight takes A5 Queen takes A5 Bishop
takes E7 something like that I mean that
could almost win the game for white uh
if we can show that variation the
problem is that uh in that sequence
black has an Intermezzo with Bishop
takes C3 very importantly because
otherwise there'd be Knight D5 check
after the king took on E7 very good
point Knight T5 picks up the queen on A5
but Bishop takes E3 grabs the Knight off
the board and now you take the bishop
and there is nothing to show for it and
Knight D4 is indeed on the board good
point there looks good for white yeah
good point there good suggestion by you
Knight D4 attacking the bishop uh black
was trying to lay claim to the C4 square
but now the bishop has to move and you
can't play Bishop C4 or anything like
that because the Knight goes to F5 as
you're mentioning so instead Maxine
plays Queen B6 and he's just aiming at
the Knight of D4 and the pawn on B2 both
can be taken care at once with the move
Castle Queen side getting the king to
defend B2 and The Rook to defend D4 yeah
and it's important to point out the
bishop defense F2 so there's no
Shenanigans with a fork white could
actually play F3 later on to chase this
Knight away but you don't always
actually want to do that because the
Knight sometimes on its own volition
drops back to E5 and of course that
threatens the very nasty Knight C4 that
that'll be a double attack on the queen
and on the B2 Pawn well you mentioned
Gary Kasparov earlier and I'm looking at
this position saying where's that sack
on C3 where's the explosive tactics on
the queen side over here Gary Kasparov
loved himself a good uh attack with the
Sicilian and here everything seems to be
defended that's the good news for Wesley
and I was just mentioning how he was up
quite a bit on time now he's actually
down on the clock trying to work his way
through the Maze of complications yeah
and and Amaze it is just because
visually it looks like Black's pieces
are a lot more active apparently the
move Knight D5 here is is very strong
just laughing in the face of danger he
played Rook C8 to control the Sea Fall
here I'll give you the C file you don't
have anything going on the C file and
after Knight C5 if black trades Robert
again the light squares are are really
really hurting black and of course the
open E file uh can also be used for
white to generate an attack on Black's
uh king that's that's stuck in the
center uh Bishop on E6 is doing the
heavy lifting here covering both D5 and
F5 as you're indicating and so that's
why it remains on E6 if Knight takes E6
F takes E6 I know we often don't love
the site of double pawns but that pawn
on E6 could actually cover key squares
and look at Wesley go he puts F4 Donya
he may strike with F5 at some point But
at the very least he's expanding
covering important Central squares you
mentioned the mega G4 often wants to
venture back to E5 that now that is no
longer on the table
yeah the complexity of the position just
keeps rising and I think it's really
reached a Zenith where black has to
figure something out on the queen side
he's made all of the low-hanging fruit
kind of moves right Rook C8 Queen B6 now
he plays Knight C4 continues to
intensify the pressure the Knight has to
move from D4 is it gonna drop back to E2
to connect with the other Knight or are
you gonna go Knight B3 or is there
another move that comes to mind like E5
wow I think E5 ripping open the D file
is important here because if black takes
that play on E5 that is not going to be
a nice outcome instead Wesley says let
me play Knight C to E2 the eval bar does
not hate it so it is a very strong
retreating move and really it's a
rerouting of pieces the Knight on C3
often looks good it feels impressive but
the Knight sometimes wants to venture on
over to the king side and inflict some
problems on that exposed black side of
the board yeah it's amazing that
visually it looks like Black's got such
a strong attack on the queen side but
there's there's so little to show for it
and it's not like Black's position is
collapsing imminent Lee Robert but it's
more that there are these cagey ideas
like Queen D3 Queen G3 and you're gonna
start harassing the Knight and you're
gonna start pressuring the rook and if
you just play the move Queen D3 you're
already threatening uh to push the pawn
down to F5 so the clock is ticking here
for mvl literally and figuratively on
the queen side
it is indeed I mean you need to get that
Rook on h8 over to C8 ASAP but that
would require you to Castle into danger
so that black king is not going over to
G8 anytime soon I don't think at least
and as soon as I said that he goes right
forward but look at the evaluation bar
it says I hate that move E7 is hanging
you're pointing to the pawn push to F5
so he wants to bring more Firepower into
the attack and now uh this D5 Square
will be whites as well so if you can
reroute a knight over there that would
be great but in the meantime E7 is
dropping white can play F5 to F6
afterwards as well to go after the H6
Pawn which will be loose I'm going to
show this on the analysis board this is
a cool line and they might follow this
line I don't say an alternative but
after Bishop D7 you grab the pawn on E7
not because you want to win a pawn right
that's never the motivation in these
types of positions but in order to pave
the way for the pawn to reach F6 I guess
the engine not a big fan of this move
maybe just do the Knight takes F6 uh and
the bloodthirsty power hungry engine
just wants to play B3 and again laughing
in the face of Ginger get off me and
after Rook C7 just a calm move Robert
like Queen F4 and you talked about heavy
lifting this Knight on D4 is a monster
it's restraining four four of Black's
pieces all of them are aiming at that
Knight directly or indirectly and they
can't do anything
that's actually incredible but what's
also incredible is what's happening in
the game continuation because after the
move F5 Maxine says sorry you want to
take my Bishop well I'm gonna go after
the C2 Pawn somehow but is it working
here after F takes E6 what does black
hamster is it rookie to check oh my
goodness Knight C2 Queen B2 is mate so
white would have to give away the queen
Wesley says I want none of it
Wesley is the calmest player on the
planet I really believe that I've said
it so many times where he just plays the
position he's not frazzled by the
thought of an attack but now let's take
stock of the position right now a rook
has been given up for that night in the
center and so what black has is a bishop
a light score Bishop for Rook now who's
King is safer the white king looking a
bit vulnerable at the moment where a
rook is staring down the sea file the
queen on B6 a bishop on A2 not threading
anything just yet but that black king on
G8 with that Rook staring down on H1 and
the queen lined up towards the H6 Pawn I
feel like as you're highlighting with F6
Knight F5 and all these types of moves
it's the black king that's ultimately
gonna fall victim to an attack yeah I
don't see a single follow-up here for
mvl so much so that I would just
consider playing F6 here Knight takes B3
is a little iffy yeah no F6 is beautiful
geometry after Bishop D1 Queen D1 you
have to play Knight F6 and The Rook on
C8 lpto Donya lpdo my favorite acronym
loose pieces drop off unbelievable
Bishop D1 Queen D1 Knight F6 you grab
the Knight and then stick the queen on
G4 forking the king and the Rook you
thought would be completely uninvolved
in any tactic and we all forced to
capture immediately okay but now the H6
Pawn is a gunner can you just take an F6
and take on H6 absolutely Bishop F6 and
Rook H6 just looks devastating
yeah the material count isn't even that
important here it's more so that the
black king is under heavy fire and look
what's happening he goes Queen takes H6
instead that looks perfectly good
because uh you are threatening all sorts
of Queen H7
you should definitely show them the
analysis board so if Bishop D4 then Rook
D4 is that a blunder we missed Queen
takes D4 no he saw it you check on H7
you check on h8 why are you trading
Queens when you're attacking well guess
what after Rook takes h8 check that
skewers The Rook on see it Robert the
poor Rook on C8 getting victimized in
every one of these lines just seamless
calculation by Wesley and mvl with a sad
move Queen d8 and at this point you're
administering the last rites yeah Queen
agent is Checkmate you sacrifice the
queen replace it with the rook and the
knight in F5 does the rest of the job
covering E7 and G7 Escape squares but
this game has all about it all about as
Wesley so takes a one point lead loose
pieces dropping off that Rook on state
was loose great recognition from Wesley
so and a great start to this last
quarterfinal here in 2022 speechless
Championship yeah one could even say a
Flawless game shades of Magnus Carlson
there so I think the internet and the
local library is just fine
and their opening in the second game is
not
we do see the Berlin if James Canty is
watching he's rolling his eyes he's
saying flexly so what are you doing but
in all seriousness this has been Maxine
versus most played opening I remember
that match against Hikaru Nakamura
several years ago all they played was
the Berlin like they were actually uh
contributing to theory in that match and
here we see the knights traded on H4 so
if we just break the board in half like
we love to do white has an extra Pawn
from E through H black has an extra Pawn
a through C but that's the problem a
through c not a through D of double
pawns here double pawns are not great
and end games hard to create past pawns
with those hey why are the players
making moves and stopping me from
drawing my little circles and arrows
that's so rude they should just pause
the game Wesley should take as long as
it takes for me to finish drawing and
look at Maxime he's taking a moment to
eat some food he always is eating in the
speeches Championship but he definitely
has a buffet on tap and he is going to
need all the energy he can get from the
food because he's down one point and
done it what do you make of this opening
what do you make of this kind of
decision from Maxime to just go with
this tried and true I think it's
admirable it's admirable that he didn't
go rookie one which has been all the
rage in the Berlin and yet it seems like
every single time white plays it he gets
absolutely nothing it's it's the
weirdest thing uh but if Wesley
continues to play the Berlin and MBL
continues to not get anything he might
also switch to the Italian so I'm going
to make an early prediction that we
actually might see uh some Italians from
mvl in the future because this position
Robert already looks like Wesley solved
essentially all of his opening problems
he's got the bishop air
I don't really know what to say about
this position but after King F7 black
and nibble around the edges I feel like
Wesley's really comfortable here this
reminds me of a game I think it was in
the aronian match that we were covering
against a draken where blood put H4 and
Rook H5 and goes after that F5 Pawn so
that was an important move from Maxime I
see the eval bar doesn't love it but the
whole point is the pawn F5 it's kind of
sticking out like a sore thumb
overextended but if black ever plays H4
now then white can play G4 to keep those
pawns connected but I do like this
position for Wesley I think the open
King side will be beneficial for him he
could put his Bishop on D6 at some point
he can try to bring his Rook from A8
over to G8 and where's that Knight going
goes to C3 but even if it gets to E4
it's not threatening anything just yet
no and it's it doesn't have anything to
grab onto it's like you're climbing a
wall and you just don't have any
footholds for your knight even if it
sits nominally in the center of course
the one thing black has to be very
careful about is not to play Bishop B7
prematurely or at all because the Rook
infiltrates to D7 not the end of the
world but this is exactly how you give
white a lot of activity and that was a
great move Rook to E8 by Wesley
threatening some things that Bishop on
E7 because the bishop on E3 is loose now
Bishop F4 seems to be a very natural
move attacking C7 but let's not forget
that pawn on F5 needs the rook's defense
so Bishop F4 threads upon but loses
sight of the pawn F5 and that's a pawn
that Wesley would have grabbed in a
hurry yeah it is and once you grab that
pawn the floodgates really open and the
light squared Bishop activates and it
does seem like MBL kind of Treading
Water right now which is really what you
do about 90 of the time in the Berlin
you just kind of wait for an opportunity
to arise but guess what Robert Bishop
takes F5 is now perhaps the first
tactical threat of the game not to
mention Rook takes E3 oh another
tactical threat you have to watch out
for because the king and Rook will be on
the same diagonal so Bishop F4 looks
okay but then Bishop C5 check is
available with F5 falling after that so
that's an important move to throw in for
black F5 cannot fall if Maxim hopes to
claim any sort of chances for a win and
yet another thing I'll point out G4
might seem to solve all the problems but
with the King still on G1 black would
have grabbed G4 and gone Rook G8 and you
actually had no way to defend the pawn
so amazingly it looks visually like
Black's Pawn structure is inferior on
the king side but you called it this F5
Fawn is a massive liability which is why
I think MBL might be preparing to put G4
that's right because he can back that G4
to G1 and Wesley makes Bishop B7 kind of
an amorphous move you don't see exactly
what the bishop is doing behind his Pawn
but then you showed C5 is up next but
look at this bishop F4 F5 is defended
now that Bishop on D6 is off the board
the D file opens that should be good for
white and this is what we were
highlighting with the pawn structure
white essentially is up a pawn in end
games because the three on two majority
on the king side you can start pushing
those pawns whereas the extra Pawn for
black on the queen side is stuck in the
mud C7 and C6 yeah the evil bar is super
deceptive here it might be equal with
perfect play but Wesley has to be very
careful in these next two or three moves
not to slip to just an inferior end game
if he takes the bishop on F4 you could
throw in an intermediate Rook D7 check
get a pair of Rooks off the board and
then recapture F4 and that's exactly
what MBL is striving for the fewer
pieces the more pronounced the
weaknesses on the king side for black
becoming the harder it becomes to put
pressure on the F5 Pawn there we go C5
by Wesley right because Bishop takes D6
is meant by Bishop takes F3 The Rook on
F3 is loose right now The Rook can slide
over to the E3 or D3 squares but then
after Bishop takes F4 you have to take
with a pawn double and isolating your F
pawns may not be the end of the world if
you can control the open file but I
don't think you want that and as you're
pointing out Knight D5 it keeps
everything nice and together they'll
close the D file and it walks into a pin
so that's actually a pretty terrifying
move I suppose you can support the
Knight with C4 but mvl says I don't care
about the pawn structure give me those
doubled pawns but give me the D file and
he's going to infiltrate the D7 Square
unless Wesley goes Bishop C6 which he
does and that's such an important move
look at the bishop on C6 it covers D7 it
restrains the knight from going to B5
which was a threat in the previous
position it also covers D5 if the Knight
goes there you can trade if you want so
the bishop on C6 is the best piece on
the board and let's not forget the G2
square if black can successfully put a
rook on G8 then there's a threat of Rook
G2 check so white needs to be very
careful here the pawns are ruined the
king is a bit exposed enough too that's
why he played Knight D5 threatening C7
Donya and covering the diagonal but this
is clearly a sign that mvl is now on the
defensive because at a minimum Wesley
could just grab the Knight and play
rookie SEMA he wants more than that he
goes rookie four what an ambitious move
but wait a second Robert
does that work out tactically Knight
takes C7
what exactly does he want in response
because there could be some exchange tax
potentially I was thinking the same
thing and there was no Rook takes F4
check Intermezzo because then the king
slides up to G3 attacking that Rook on
F4 right so Knight C7 detects the rook
and eight and if you take on F4 your
second Rook will be loose there so it's
actually I think an oversight
potentially by Wesley well I think he
missed 96 I think he sees Knight takes
C7 but he thinks oh after Rooks the
eight the Pawn's hanging the knights
hanging then I can return to E6 which is
the best Square on the board I mean
white wouldn't have dreamed of getting a
knight to a square like that The Rook on
e4 is stranded The Exchange sack becomes
a lot more of a reality with the Rook
from E4 cut off from the E7 Square
definitely an oversight by Wesley and a
big one at that yeah kind of strange we
don't expect Wesley to make that kind of
mistake he was Rook to G8 so that Bishop
on C6 is very powerful and look at
Wesley so cool so calm King to E7 and
now you really have to watch out for
Rook G2 check maybe not immediately but
sometimes you can sacrifice a rook on
the Square to drag the king onto a
diagonal for Discovery but also Rook
takes E6 extreme sacrifice of his own
followed by Rook G2 check that's also in
the cards potentially and we so take for
granted no pun intended the way that
Wesley recovers from a blunder or an
oversight where so many people you know
you have the common phrase one mistake
follows another blunders occur in pairs
you know whatever cliche uh you want to
put forth in this case Wesley really
bucks the trend he manages to make the
most out of the situation after an
unfortunate blunder but the thing is MBL
doesn't need a wide margin uh to punish
you and this is looking real iffy as the
king moves up to F3 Robert The Rook is
attacked where's it gonna go as you
point out cut off from the rest of the
pieces you would love to be able to
bring that Rook back on the e-file but
no can do so is it going to A4 he goes
C4 but that's a whoa losing mistake and
what if I play C3 trying to arrest test
The Rook or is there something like
Knight C7 here with perhaps a mating
attack against the king oh my gosh
you're also clearing the E6 Square oh a
knight D5 too but oh no five as well
everything is in the air there and
Knight C7 plane so I think Wesley missed
97 two different times in this game
first giving up the pawn now the night
going back and with Rook E6 check the
bishop and B5 hanging just a simple move
C3 as you mentioned to try to trap that
Rook on C4 I feel like Wesley down a
pawn and without really a threat of his
own yeah and I sung his Praises there
but he really did make two blunders
virtually in a row first plundering C7
and then shifting his Rook to the wrong
Square maybe a rookie two would have
enabled him to stay alive and now I just
think Rook E6 and then stacking the
Rooks on the sixth rank that looks
pretty juicy once F6 Falls not only are
you down a bunch of Pawns but you're
also getting checkmated there yeah
that's just over I mean you win the F6
Pawn by force uh the King on F3 there
are no checks against it it's very
important that black ball wearing H4 or
we'd be telling a different tale right
now but the King on F3 is the much safer
of the two kings and this looks very
straightforward Maxine doing the right
thing though he does have plenty of time
to convert this Advantage he's trying to
be precise because you make one
inaccuracy that Wesley's right back in
the game yeah and you should leave
yourself with something like 10 seconds
here uh just to take care of the
logistics he decides on Knight to D5
which is essentially the same thing Rook
takes F6 and then the Rook slides over
to G1 and there's gonna be some sort of
mating construction there is no way the
black is surviving this no and Wesley
down under 20 seconds himself takes in
c21 is hanging so be careful with that
what do you spot Donya King G7 Rook G1
King H7 Rook F7 and Knight F6 you can
actually sack The Rook on G1 but Wesley
goes the other way so it's a moot point
okay and the Eva bar Sky High right now
so there must be something that causes
black to lose material there could be a
knight E3 at any moment but the bishop
goes to E4 with check so instead you go
to E7 still what's dodging and bucking
and hiding but now the F1 just promotes
and you can't go Bishop G6 because of
the fork again on what scar E7 so great
geometrical awareness from Maxine
vasilograph he has a degree an advanced
degree in math so no surprise there he
wins game two now it's one to one that
was a great game by MBL just the way
that he punished Wesley's blunder he was
patient out of the opening but still
definitely uncharacteristic by Wesley to
give up a pawn like that but if you're
mvl you just have to exploit every
single one of these opportunities you're
not going to get a lot of them and
Maxime goes back to the Sicilian it's
something that needs to be talked about
is Maxime wrote on his blog about how he
has changed his second his trainers so
with a new team that is working with him
on chess perhaps that means new openings
that was one of the major criticisms of
Maxine versus that he was too
predictable always playing the same
exact variations you're playing Maxine
you're getting a Berlin you're getting a
grundfeld you're getting his Sicilians
his beloved nightors but now we're
seeing him play Knight C6 on move two a
la Magnus Carlson in the world champion
match against five undercarwana it was
became all the rage and so we see him
diversifying and I think that will
benefit him as a player I I certainly
think it will and there was a very
painful tournament mvo competed and I
think it was taught to steal forget
which year 2018-19 he played I think the
Knight or three times in a row and lost
three games in Norwalk he lost the game
I remember it's a van Forest I think he
lost to Carolina and everybody was
playing Bishop G5 F4 and prepping the
heck out of him and it was is really
just a sign that you really can't
survive in this day and age with just
one opening you could do it in 1970 very
successfully you could even do it in
2005 but you really can't do it in 2022
you need a little bit of diversity no
matter how well you know your main
opening very true and look at this
position by the way we have talked about
the night or open positions from game
one here it's very close we had a
russellimo there's uh this no Pawn
tension in the center until just now F7
to F6 Ben Feingold he may be rolling his
eyes and said what are you doing what is
trying to crack open the center The Rook
of the Fate will improve the bishop G7
will improve and as you're just pointing
out the Knight now has an escape score
because F3 thread to trap it yeah that's
a Swiss army knife kind of move
accomplishes a lot of different things
but the immediate threat was indeed F3
mm-hmm and so we see a simple capture on
F6 and that was a big question which
piece do you take he takes at the pawn
isolating his own d-pawn but taking away
important squares and there it is F6
covers E5 B6 covers C5 that Knight on D3
it looks very good but it's covered by
the enemy pawns yeah it's kind of like
that Knight in the Berlin end game it
just doesn't have a lot of footholds in
the center you could go Knight F4 but
that seems like a paper tiger after
Bishop F7 looks like mvl has not only
solved all of his opening problems I
would say that he's posed some problems
to white as well yes because if that
Knight goes back to D6 which it can
right now in it goes that F5 or C4 with
greater effect so Wesley has completed
his minor piece development but he's
also compromised some of his squares the
dark squares on the king side uh the C4
square is blacks for the taking as we've
been discussing but where from there
that's the big question it can be a
symbolic Advantage an aesthetically
pleasing position but now you have to go
into the next gear and actually create
concrete threats yeah and he continues
to make one move for us there's Bishop
H6 asking The Rook a polite or not so
polite question where are you gonna go
Rook C2 does close off the queen and I
think it's important to keep a pathway
back to uh safety for the queen but mvl
continues to deploy his pieces one after
the other and the pressure continues to
intensify
and just the awkward placement of
White's pieces right this Rook is now in
E2 you want to double that's clear but
the knight in D3 it's not really doing
all that much and there's nowhere to go
and look at Maxim the calm move Bishop
F7 I know your threat is Rook to E1 so
I'm anticipating that and now I'm
getting my Bishop out of the way so I
don't have to move to the next turn but
what's his plan here done is he'll trade
Rooks who does that benefit yeah that's
kind of what I'm trying to figure out
and generally it benefits the side that
lacks space the lacks activity but the
situation might be subtly different here
I think if all four pair if all four
Rooks disappeared black would still be
slightly better no question about it and
mvl has the same opinion so what you're
telling me down here is that a bishop
pair is a good thing just to be clear I
believe I am caught guilty yep okay
thank you you got me not only does black
have the bishop here though in all
seriousness the bishop and H6 excuse me
is so much better than the bishop 1 F2
right the bishop 186 slicing across the
whole diagonal the bishop 1 F2 staring
into its own Pawn so look at Wesley Play
Moves Like A 4. what's the threat there
is none maybe trying to give himself the
B5 Square
um I feel like black has ideas in the
future White's at a point where you're
just making moves for now yeah A4 not
really a move that carries an idea is
just trying to pass the turn but not
easy for mvl also to figure out a way uh
to intensify the pressures as Tara said
good positions don't win games good
pieces don't win games good moves win
games where is that additional gear that
mvl needs to jump into here in order to
actually cause cracks in White's
position is it Queen F5 is it something
more creative what comes to mind well
what comes to mind is there's always
some Knight takes B2 tactics for black
because the Knight on C3 can be a bit
loose I was not expecting to move A5
that's for sure but what I was thinking
about is if white ever played through
Queen B5 trying to take with that a pawn
then Knight takes B2 tactics were there
so instead of you know allowing anything
funny on the queen side Maxi plays A5
that creates a weak this on B6 but it's
I think a weakness in terms of looks but
it's hard to get to and queen B5 has
been played but he recaptures with the
Knight now there's no more Knight takes
B2 tactics
where to from here if you're mvl I think
A5 to A6 let's push that point yeah
exactly kick it away but there is Wesley
taking advantage in a sense of that pawn
push it can't go backwards and now white
can play B3 and Knight to D6 at some
point so I I don't really love the idea
of B3 just because that pawn can
actually be targeted with Knight to D2
but if it allows a fork to happen then
it'll be worth it whoa where's that
Bishop what's it doing well it forces
The Rook trade I was going to point this
move out I think he wants Bishop takes
E8 Rook to uh sorry Rook takes a bishop
takes E8 and then maybe you can snap the
Knight off the board but that doesn't
necessarily solve all of your problems
there's some crazy tactics
Robert with a knight takes B2 move after
Bishop takes the eight if white goes
rookie six maybe you can actually take
on B5 and take on B2 using the back rank
check to justify this so white I think
has to stay on the first rank that's
such a good point it's very instructive
actually so we uh can try to pull up an
analysis board and show that because if
the Rook slides up the board then the
background problems are real as you just
showed yeah rookie six first you take
the Knight then you take the pawn now
earlier the point of this move was that
there was a hanging piece but here after
Knight takes P2 you throw in the check
on C1 you force white to give the bishop
away amazingly this is not the end of
the story because Bishop takes you what
there's Knight D3 but you get the point
this seems too scary and Wesley agrees
he's played Rook to D1 and another
reason he wants to keep the Rook on the
first rank is in the event of Bishop
takes B5 a takes B5 black will play Pawn
to A4 and then there will be again
Knight takes B2 sacrifices with a
running a pawn so that's something that
Wesley needs to keep a close eye on he
also needs to keep an eye on Maxine's
clock because Maxine is down about a
minute so that's not the best news for
the Frenchman with three names but his
position does remain very strong with
the B5 Pawn as you have highlight here
that's going to be Target after Knight
D6 just debilitating weaknesses on the B
file both of these pawns are sitting
ducks you pointed out Knight D6 the
Knight can't move away from D3 actually
Knight D6 might be a massive threat
because if you lose a pawn I think it's
safe to say that at that point with a
two on one and more active pieces
Black's gonna have a technically winning
position so Wesley trying to prevent it
at all costs but now he's allowed a
check on E3 this is looking real bad
yeah Bishop E3 check Bishop F2 will
likely be forced there and you can swap
pieces and Knight takes B2 oh there it
is amazing there was a back rank idea
then there's a second rank idea and
Wesley just resigns because he's going
to lose a second Pawn after all is said
and done he's gonna lose a second pawn
and now he's lost a second game in a row
Maxine vashir lagrav the friendship with
three names he jumps to a one point lead
and of course we go back to the Beloved
Berlin and it's a bit different this
time not the queen trade variation but
instead the position where white rookie
two I love this move because B6 is what
black plays and then rookie one is the
follow-up because the whole point is
black wants the structure with the D7
Pawn on D5 which is why rookie 2 is
actually okay it looks odd your Bishop 1
F1 is stuck at home but you're
eventually going to double pieces on the
e-file so yeah this is typical
Grandmaster chess in 2022. if this move
had been played in 1970 would have been
a mouse slip or a hand slip I forgot to
drag The Rook all the way to E1 but now
these kinds of moves are standard fare
provoking a weakness you know putting a
roof book or putting a piece on a
seemingly awkward Square for very subtle
reasons all of that is kind of a
Hallmark of super Grand Master chess in
this day and age but what is White gonna
do now is he going to go Knight c394 is
he going to push the pawn up to C4 I
really don't understand these positions
very much yeah oftentimes white plays C3
to take away the D4 Square from Black's
pieces and then brings a knight into the
E4 square and just one more note about
this rookie 2 move it was played by
Magnus Carlson in His World Chess
Championship Match in 2016 against
karyakin and at the moment he played
rookie two I remember being like is
Maxime working with him because Maxime
actually had a game in that variation
and I immediately messaged Maxine I'm
like hey you know off the Record because
I know this kind of stuff is personal
what's up with this and he was very Coy
in his response so
um it was later known that Maxim did
work with Magnus some for that match but
here it's uh years later and the point
Still Remains the Same white has more
space to on D5 restricts that black
Bishop on C8 in particular and in Comes
This Knight to E4 after the move
see-through is played taking away the D4
Square yeah I mean 2016 you mentioned
were there airplanes then that around
the time Joan of Arc was burdened at the
stake I mean a completely different era
but it's it's awesome that this rookie
one line has really persisted across now
you know well over half a decade so it's
it's withstood the test of time
and uh White's position is just
generally a little bit more pleasant in
these types of situations as Wesley
tries to disrupt the center with a very
committal C7 C6 pawn move yeah that's
thematic but it's difficult to play and
I'm pretty sure I've had this exact
position as black and several times and
I always lose because this opponent D6
is a long-term weakness if you ever take
on D5 white simply can take back then
the pawn on B7 is hanging because
there's a queen on D5 the pawn structure
just remains Superior for white so
that's an issue and after F4 here you
see that the bishop on E5 has to go back
to F6 you could take the bishop pair
Donya but that's not the end of the
story because the bishop on C1 it
doesn't yet have the best home and
White's king is not the happiest I mean
once you push F4 you create weaknesses
long-term weaknesses on the A7 G1
diagonal so both sides have their pluses
and minuses here what is the bishop pair
white is a good Pawn on D5 but his
pieces are still pretty undeveloped and
he's got some long-term King side
weaknesses I'd estimate the position as
as being approximately equal yeah it's
one of those positions with a dynamic
equality right it's not just locked up
both sides of the same pieces it's that
black can go after this white king as
you mentioned it's a bit exposed and
look at the Rook on A1 not attached to
the Rook on E1 so at some point Rook E8
might just try to trade off Rooks and
get the second Rook to the E5 but look
at Maxine though right after the B7 Pawn
Dunya is it as you like to say a paper
tiger or is that pawn really threatened
and that thus Wesley has to react oh
it's annoying it's it's really annoying
Queen takes B7 is most definitely
actually a threat like if you take that
pun the whole Queen side collapses and
you don't just want to carelessly play
B6 maybe you will play V6 but you then
have to reckon with d takes C6 and you
have to take back with the bishop this
D6 Pawn as a result is going to be a bit
of a liability he goes for it so it's a
calculated decision but I would imagine
that mvl is going to take on C6 here
although allowing that light squid
Bishop Robert to get onto the long
diagonal is itself also a concession so
such a positionally difficult situation
to handle because every move seems to
have a lot of pluses and minuses major
consequence abound and as you're saying
dc6 Bishop C6 Knight H4 probably in the
near future the white king would come
under Fire very quickly and so he plays
Bishop D2 does Maxime he's saying let me
develop my pieces if you take on D5 I
take with my queen and very importantly
that Bishop on D7 doesn't get to the
long diagonal at least not yet and thus
keeping the white King on G1 safe so uh
Rook E8 feels very natural to me from
Wesley's perspective you could consider
playing the move C5 done yet I know that
seems a bit risky on the light squares
but if we could eventually trade light
Square Bishops the Knight on F5 is just
the dominant piece the bishop on D2 has
no future and with opponent C5 keeping
the pawn structure intact files closed
the only open files the e-file and black
is ready to play rookie 8 next yeah C5
very much abides by typical positional
rules when you're facing the bishop pair
and you've got the Knight you want to
close up the center so see if 5 actually
makes perfect sense to me I was also
thinking about C takes D5 Queen takes D5
and then Rook a to C8 in order to
prepare Bishop C6 but then white would
deploy the light squared Bishop himself
and beat Black to the punch Knight to E7
that I was not expecting jeez not at all
and I'm already looking to move like C4
at some point to get my Bishop to C3 but
I guess Wesley is putting to Target the
D5 Pawn uh the Knight and pawn and C6
both attacking it C4 looks very good but
if you are not precise here you may drop
a pawn in the center and you definitely
do not want to do that and maybe the
right move is just to play D takes C6
and after Bishop takes C6 the long
diagonal Robert seems so much less
menacing with the Knight no longer able
to jump into H4
very true and if that Bishop on D2 can
go to D4 then we're going to start
talking about a white Advantage thanks
to the activity of the bishop pair so it
takes in Z6 Bishop takes back and Bishop
E3 the good news is after Knight F5 you
can put your Bishop on F2 which is a
much better Square than D2 staring over
at the queen side as well and covering
the H4 Square yeah the bishop isn't
going to be the greatest piece on the
board but at the very least it's going
to fulfill a crucial defensive Duty and
mvl does just that Knight D5 by the way
also to be considered here in order to
pressure the F4 Pawn Knight D5 actually
looks quite annoying and maybe the F4
Pawn is going to be sacrificed after
Knight D5 Bishop D4 gives up the F4 pawn
and try to finish the development use
the f file to his Advantage was mvl's
thought but instead Rook E8 a very quiet
move a very Wesley so move Donya
yeah yeah I mean I would play Knight D5
or Knight of five ten times out of ten
but Wesley he likes to keep his options
open and his position as flexible as
possible part of the main one of the
many reasons it's so hard to face him in
Blitz I thought you're about to say one
of the many reasons why James candy
calls him flexley so flexley oh that was
low hanging fruit that I didn't pick oh
man well that was literally right in my
face wasn't it Maxime has been picking
all the fruit that is needed from the
you know four bases on screen right now
and he plays rook ad1 and he wants to
pick off that isolated Pawn on D6 that
is not a good pawn and if you push it to
D5 it's Ultra well defended but the
bishop on C6 becomes a big Pawn so
Knight G6 played instead if G3 here to
defend the pawn F4 there still could be
Knight H4 that King on G1 will be wide
open yeah G3 is not a move you play
unless you're totally desperate Maxime
defending the pawn from a distance and
simultaneously hitting the pawn on D6 so
we might see Rook a to d8 here uh in
order to keep that pawn under control
you definitely don't want to play D5 and
close off the bishop that's for sure not
a movie you want to play but you need to
defend this Pawn so Rook 88 does do just
that but then you're kind of losing
control of the queen side so he plays
rookie six why not let's double Brooks
and there is no F4 to F5 that's the one
scary thing about putting your Rook on
E6 is it could be a baby fork with that
pawn moving up but the queen has that
square covered yeah great Point Queen
covers F5 The Rook coming to E8 is black
resting control of the initiative from
White's hands I I think he might be
Robert looks like it I mean black is all
the activity white has a Superior Pawn
structure but at what cost it took many
moves to give black this isolated pawn
and in the meantime look at all of
Black's pieces that Knight on G6 aiming
at the F4 pawn and the H4 Square Queen
D4 I think is a very uh smart decision
by Maxine because even if he loses the
pawn let's say queen D4 Bishop D4 Knight
takes F4 he's probably thinking with the
bishop pair my losing chances are not
that high yeah it's absolutely worth it
and queen takes D4 he might want to
consider C takes D4 that creates a big
Pawn on E3 that's not a pleasant move
but I agree I mean any end game here
Pawn down or not he's gonna have good
drawing chances so if you're Wesley
you're looking for a way to avoid the
queen trade there is the move Queen F5
here and after Bishop D3 the queen
slides into G4 but I mean at that point
the margin is very thin maybe Queen f5h3
Wesley doesn't want something this
speculative so he takes on D4 Rook takes
D4 is also possible but then I was Rook
to E8 an awkward pain along the e-file
and maybe King F2 is the easy response
and white could actually be better in
this end game right the bishop pair the
Superior Pawn structure the Knight on G6
not exactly where it needs to be so
Donya I think that Knight needs to
reroute to F5 once again
yeah 97 possible here or after rookie 8
King F2 but then White's Bishop might
slide up just in time to D3 perhaps also
97 to D5 could be rather unpleasant
hitting the bishop pressuring F4 but
whoa just a bailout I think by mvl and
this will likely lead to a very drawish
end game yes and D5 now play we we're
talking how we don't shut down the
bishop but with limited material
remaining this looks quite level look at
the activity of blackstroke on E5
White's Rook on D4 perfectly situated
done it that isolated Pawn is blockaded
and if pieces get traded here the Rooks
get traded and the black king is so
active I don't think white has real
winning chances so with the superiorly
place king that's where I think black's
uh saying I have this all under control
although if Magnus Carlson had this
position with the white pieces yesterday
I would be quivering in my boots like I
would be like it's a bygone conclusion
that he'll find a way to win if Wesley
remains careful if he doesn't blunder
the D5 Fawn this should be eminently
drawable but look at the clock by the
way Westing on 14 seconds Maxima just
under 20. so this is getting the
territory where you can certainly make a
mistake if you are getting that low on
the clock oh yeah I mean the Rooks could
get traded at the wrong moment he tries
to trade them at the right moment and
the important thing is that he gets his
King to E5 if White's King had reached
D4 that would have been mighty
unpleasant now it just Fizzles out and
neither side can make any progress and a
big lesson here do not take on B4
because white will take with the c pawn
and create an outside pass Pawn so
that's the one thing that black cannot
afford with the tension the way it is
it's just always going to be an offer a
trade nothing no past pawns to be scared
of that's exactly right and what's funny
is yes okay he didn't take with the
seatbelt because D4 check was at the
right time so that's why he takes the a
pawn and now we're just repeating moves
yeah Wesley declined to draw there he
wanted to make a couple more moves just
torture mvl
for a little while longer but good
defensive effort by mvl because it got
really dicey at one moment and that
decision to go into the pawn down while
potentially Pawn down endgame was a very
wise one and look at Maxine vasilaga
playing dodgeball he has gone back to
the night or he played that Russell limo
2 Knight C6 just uh his previous time
with the black pieces so Maxime is going
to be more difficult to pin down this
match than he has been in classical
chess over the last decade for sure and
that I think is a very positive
adjustment and this time he pushes the
pawn to G4 you might remember that in
game one he played G takes H4 this is an
attempt at an improvement yes and he has
not had time to look at the opening
right these games happen as soon as the
previous one ends and so we see a castle
Queen side we see a bit more of a closed
position this time around because the
exchange of pause didn't happen but done
I still like this for white like every
time I see this position I'm like
Black's Pawn on the king said
overextended I don't see an attack
happening quickly enough for the black
pieces and I just feel like the
potential is there for Wesley to just
slowly improve his pieces I'm on the
same page I agree I think white is
objectively better I my eyes are always
drawn to these weaknesses on the king
side the H5 Square imagine a knight
getting to H5 and forcing the bishop
back that would be really unpleasant but
MBL is saying hey basically all of my
pieces are aimed at the king side and
Knight C4 is I think a pretty serious
threat now that that Wesley has to deal
with maybe with a with a well-timed C3
it's a blunt the bishop and get it to
bite on granite yeah for sure Knight C4
is very annoying because the B2 Pawn is
loose he plays C3 which also allows him
to play Knight D4 if he wants we saw
that uh in an earlier game he brought
his Knight back from B3 to D4 but with
the Knight attack of the queen on D2
here's the big question do we take on C4
which opens the B file that looks scary
to me or do I just move my queen
somewhere and if so where to because the
bishop on G7 and Knight and C4 were
causing some serious problems there and
that's why Wesley captured on C4 yeah I
don't know I thought moving the queen
might have been the Lesser evil there
now he's given the mvl the B file and of
course the C4 Pawn as you like to point
out restricts greatly restricts the
mobility of the Knight on C1 you can't
bring it up to D3 you can't bring it up
to B3 what you can do is try to
circumvent that on and move into F4 he
puts a Pawn on F4 so he's trying to
provoke on passant and open up the king
side but is this fast enough and does
MBL have a crazy move like F5 in store
wow F5 was actually a nasty move
undermining the defender of that night
on D5 potentially trying to open up the
diagonal the bishop on E6 would have
thrived on the h7b1 Diagon but instead
he captures once on passant plus Queen
A5 I think we understand what he's doing
done he would love to get that Rook on
h8 just like in the previous game over
to the queen side but we saw what
happened the last time he did it he
castled kingside into a vicious attack
and lost the game so how in the world is
he gonna get the Rook on h8 over to the
queen side for an attack yeah that's the
big question because as it stands he
doesn't quite have enough Firepower to
really deliver on the queen side he's
got a bunch of tempting moves I was
gonna say 95 and Knight D3 looks real
juicy but when she's supposed to say
Over My Dead Body Knight D4 to C6 oh
and then Rook takes B2 Queen takes B2
and the queen hangs at the end of the
line yeah I think Knight D4 is available
you do have to calculate Bishop takes D5
and all that kind of stuff but I do like
the look of bringing the Knight up in
the position and otherwise I guess you
could take on E5 as your hand you could
take I I think you should take because
that night was a tremendous attacking
asset just the Bishops alone might not
have the skill that they need to display
to really crack through on the queen
side and now there's F4 you can drop the
Knight back to E3 whenever you want
although Bishop takes D5 isn't really a
big threat is there F4 here and if
Bishop back to G7 like a knight takes E7
tactic oh so he has to take this way and
now how do you take back I think Queen
trade is the end game good for white
he takes back with the pawn there was
maybe bishop takes C3 there I'm not sure
that's actually a very good tactical
sequence good eye by you there not
surprising that you are spotting those
uh but here I feel like White's Pawn
structure is damaged Black's King is a
lot safer King D7 is actually a viable
option for black and if you really want
to bring that Rook on h8 over to the
queen side at long last and it was
really hurting like that you can't go
like Knight g394 because the C3 Pawn
constantly drops so white would kill for
the king to be on A1 but that doesn't
actually eliminate Rook takes B2 tactics
in their entirety so a kind of calm move
by Wesley I think he's preparing Knight
D4 and he saw King D7 because King D7
could be met by Queen F5 check just yep
putting that King on the C5 which is not
where it wants to be so Rook G8 played
by Maxime he's taken a drink of whatever
is in that plastic bottle uh he's always
eating and drinking and now he's just
trying to uncork some pressure on the
king side he's playing on both sides of
the board yeah this game is turned
around in the last three or four moves
it did feel like Wesley was having the
upper hand and then suddenly a bunch of
these pieces get traded and now I'm
gonna be all definitely in the driver's
seat now you don't necessarily want to
rush the move Rook G2 because you're
going to have to reckon with Queen E4
but there are some beautiful tactics if
we can pull up an analysis board real
fast just to give you a flavor of the
kind of stuff that can happen Rook G2
Queen E4 and hey maybe this will happen
Rook takes E2 Queen takes C2 and now
there's Rook takes B2 sacking a second
rook and you basically have to give your
queen up because if you take with the
King you get checkmated Queen A1 check
and then Queen B2 is made I've seen so
many of these combinations in my day
when I was playing the Knight arf oh for
sure because once their King is met with
a rook on an open file there are all
sorts of cycles and King D7 was played
Knight up to D4 Knight C6 is a threat
Queen F5 check keeping that in your back
pocket so black has some options here I
mean queen takes D5 not out of the
question there is no tactical shot just
because the queen of Rook are on the
same line does not mean that suddenly
your Queen's in danger so Queen 65 but
there's Queen A4 check and Wesley I mean
he thinks he might be going after that
black king but it looks according to the
evaluation bardonya that Maxim's King is
doing just fine Queen A4 check just King
C7 and again Knight E6 Jack there was
Queen take C6 so Wesley trying to
quickly accumulate his pieces in the
center now Queen a4check is a big threat
because 96 is going to be available but
mvl has a Tempo to deal with that he can
eliminate the Knight does anything else
come to mind maybe move the queen away
from D5 but where exactly do you put it
maybe you put it on C5 I was thinking
back to A5 potentially as well just the
uh the A4 Square where but that's at the
end of the story right the White Queen
is ready to venture into the position
with Queen E4 ideas and things of that
nature and what white wants to do is
double Rooks on one of the files because
doubling Brooks not just threatens or
goes at the black king but protects the
second rank so look at Maxine player
Rook B6 in the evaluation bar it's on
the Seesaw going back up and down back
up and down Queen A4 check he wants to
dip back to C8 and then Knight E6 is
still possible but parrot really is a
paper tiger because it only threatens
the queen and it's not a check well I
can just meet that with Queen B5 also
would be surprised if a queen SEC isn't
that bad for black like if you take on
E6 with a pawn then recapture The Rook
that takes the queen on D5 with the pawn
and use the G file and the B file to
your advantage
no you're absolutely right that's a good
point one minute now for Wesley so as he
struggles to come up with a way to
generate counter play he attempts Knight
to F5
but I just don't see where he's going
with this black is so watertight in the
center Rook G2 Rook G2 possible yeah
that's what I was looking at because
you're hitting the queen on C2 the pawn
and B2 behind it if Queen A4 check
trying to escape the pressure the queen
goes to B5 offering a queen trade and
it's played and now Westy's in huge
trouble and I think he's just losing
because if he has to move the queen back
well where do you move it the knight's
also going to be hanging Queen B1 may be
but even Bishop takes C3 has to be
considered there and that's I mean I'm
sure there's there's a simpler options
as well like Queen A5 yeah no because
Queen me one is your best move you're
you know you're in huge trouble no move
yet from Wesley and maybe the move to
the library right in the snowstorm that
he's facing in Minnesota maybe that's
rattled him in the early stages but
credit is due to Maxine vasilograph
who's Come Out Swinging right he is not
just playing calm quiet openings he wins
this game goes up three and a half one
half done yet so five games in it's
really been a masterful display okay
from Maxine vashilograph that first game
was perfectly played by Wesley but it's
gone downhill ever since and mvl kudos
to him for repeating the same opening
making an improvement he played G4
rather than G takes H4 and just a
Flawless tactical display on the queen
side so mvl he's getting the kinds of
positions he wants he's playing quickly
he's sharp and he holds a two-point lead
as we hit a halfway point of the five
plus one segment Robert easy to forget
that what you just mentioned Wesley
actually won game one looked very good
in that game but since then Maxime has
rideed the ship he is up two points as
we head to the second half of the five
plus one time Patrol so with that in
mind the players are on a break we're
gonna do the same and we're in return
it's more from this matchup between
Maxine vashilagrove and Wesley so here
at the speeches championship
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
as we return here to the speeches
championship match between Wesley so and
Maxine Russia lagrove in the
quarterfinals we really need no
introduction to Wesley but Dania he is
the first ever chess.com Global Champion
I'm sure many people here were watching
that event and look at that lifetime
record right 29 years old but that's
what sticks out to me is his massive
overall record here in the SEC
yeah I mean he's just been the picture
of consistency Robert every year he just
he's just such a professional and he
doesn't get too high with the highs
didn't get too low with the lows you
pointed it out the only people he's ever
lost to were Magnus Carlson and he car
or Nakamura that stat really does speak
for itself
it does but Maxine vasilograph looking
to make history he won the world Blitz
Championship a year ago now he wants to
take down Wesley so he'll be the first
player not named Magnus or Hikaru to do
that and Wesley he had to move to the
local library that probably was
uncomfortable you know you like to be in
your typical setup but as we have him on
camera you as we keep talking about he
is as stoic as a chess player gets he
really is and you can see that heavy
duty jacket he was wearing to make it
through the library but Wesley I mean
he's modest you know he he adapts
himself to his surroundings and his
circumstances and let's see if you can
you know get his feet under him he's
only down by two that's really not a
significant lead and the match really is
just getting started and he will not
make any excuses Wesley's so you know
he's just here to play he's ready to do
his thing and we'll see if he's able to
recover from a two-game deficit at the
moment we see a Berlin with the trade
symmetrical Pawn structure down there I
think we're gonna get a whole lot of
this today oh yeah a healthy dose of
Berlin especially I think Maxime is
going to keep repeating this as long as
he's up in the match because this is a
relatively relatively risk-free
continuation for white so no need for
MBL
to do anything wild plus this is of
course what he's analyzed now you
mentioned rookie one the idea of
provoking B6 very interesting yes and so
the pawn would like to be on D5 for
black uh but that's not really going to
happen and if it does the bishop B7 is
uh going to be behind you so Bishop F4
simple development now or Maxime and the
Knight comes up to E4 so I have to admit
Dania I'm not that familiar with the ins
and outs of this opening but already the
Knight venturing into E4 rather than F5
that's an interesting twist for my eyes
yeah we could get a battle of the
Bishops here if the knights are traded
on D2 black could also try to trade on
his own terms with a move like rookie
eight or maybe even D5 but it's it's
really really hard to make heads or
tails of this it's it's a complicated
positional struggle
for sure and Knight D2 now as they think
from Wesley the D4 Pawn is threatened
can't be captured with the Knight E4
being loose and if Knight takes D2 Queen
takes E2 well the pawn on D4 is defended
the Rooks are connected even though the
pawn material on material as I said Pawn
structure and material are one and the
same it's still a slight Advantage for
white if you take on D2 because White's
Rooks are connected Robert what's the
pawn material
oh yeah seven pawns on the board that's
right it's a new measurement that's what
the cool kids use now it is right yeah
there's the metric system there's the
pawn count system and here there's
Knight takes D2 in the Berlin system
against the Royal Lopez and we see a
bunch of Trades will he take on D4
that's the question because if black
took on D4 white could take on H7 with
check and then win that Bishop we get
opposite color Bishops uh that looks to
me to still be all right but that's one
of those big questions that the players
have to figure out yeah it is and it
leads to a completely different type of
position black is essentially two moves
away from fully equalizing I'm in Queen
D7 and then uh and then rookie eight I
think are gonna be Wesley's next moves
but MV only doesn't seem too concerned
he just kind of goes C3 does he really
have anything once The Rook gets to E8
Robert or am I missing something massive
about this position this just looks dead
equal he's get some delicious looking
food that's all I'm seeing that's
he's happy he's getting himself a nice
hearty meal but he doesn't really have
anything you are correct so the one
thing perhaps he can claim is that the
Rook coming to E1 if he can control the
e-file first then there would be a
slight Advantage but rookie one is met
by rookie eight and so you can't line
your heavy pieces up in time yeah there
would be a riveting sequence after
rookie won rookie eight rookie three
trade and then put a queen on E7 trade
that and while we kind of know where
that's heading to drawville USA
consolation Wesley so mix human
Telegraph population of at least two and
probably many more but you're right
Daniel there's just nothing here and for
Maxime why does he have to fret about
this he has a two-point lead not taking
any risks it is a little bit early well
a lot early to be thinking about
deficits heading into bullet and things
like that but I'm going to ask you
anyway wow Bishop F5 attack sequence
taking control over the last rank that's
important here but to finish my question
Dania if the players one of them has a
two-point lead do you think that they're
close enough in bullet where either
player can come back because Hikaru says
about himself as long as he's within two
games heading into bullet he feels like
he's the favorite what do you make of
these players and their speeches I feel
like two points is nothing I I really
feel like I with players of strength
that's so equivalent again no pun
intended I mean this is just this fruit
is too low hanging I I feel like a
two-point lead can can turn around at
the drop of a hat so both of these
players are more than capable of putting
together even a three or four game
winning streak if they build up a lot of
momentum so I would say that Wesley
should only start getting concerned when
the lead hits you know three or maybe
four even
that would be really out of control and
right now this position is anything but
out of control yeah equal material
Queens are coming off now the one
question is if you take on E3 will white
take with the F Pawn and then try to
push that pawn doesn't really amount to
much anyway but it just changes the
dynamic a little bit Yeah and maybe you
just go Queen E7 here just to not allow
white even the possibility of f takes uh
E3 I I don't see a downside to uh to
keeping the tension with Queen E7 maybe
you can get away with King f8 but again
giving up the H7 Pawn you have to
calculate an M lazy
so he takes only three F takes either of
course played by Maxime and the evil bar
actually started to swing a little bit
in Black's favor I don't think it means
that much at the moment but I am
wondering why that could be yeah because
if I had to choose a side intuitively
you might think that white is the one
pushing
because he's got at least optically the
more active Bishop so that's actually an
illusion the bishop on B7 is really
strong and why does this possibility of
pushing the E4 Pawn up but obviously
Robert right now that's Unthinkable E4
runs into G6 and all you're doing is
just losing your pawns right so can't
afford to do that just yet
um king of Fate says please go full
Fisher and take on H7 yeah I'll play G6
and your Bishop will be trapped over
there so Bishop D3 played by Maxime that
will allow him to play Pawn to E4 and
very importantly black can't play D5 to
try to control that square because C7 is
loose so I think that white is about to
gain more space the king is going to be
line for the E3 square and I'm starting
to appreciate Maxim's position more and
more and maybe Wesley he's recognizing
and look at his clock dipping under a
minute and a half that this is not just
a drawn end game it actually takes some
work yeah this is actually exactly what
you want when you've got a two-point
lead a risk-free position where you're
up on time and you get to torture your
opponent even more and guess what if
Wesley defends you take off your hat and
you agree to a draw so this is what MBL
had in mind when he was playing rookie
one against the Berlin that's right and
H6 played by Wesley will he played
Bishop G5 next that's one of those
questions how do trades impact the
position because Bishop G5 I think
forces the Bishops off the board because
you don't want to play Bishop G3 and
allow Bishop to C1 so great Point what
do you make of it do you play G3 to try
to get more pawns toward the center he
says no let me double your pawns I still
think we're heading toward a draw I I
just don't see anything wow okay
yeah I didn't make it out entirely yeah
I don't remember what I said there but
um whatever I said they were they were
greatly influenced by it of course as
they usually are they made a draw on the
spot normally I'm against draw offers
I'm okay with that one it was a
completely level end game deep down the
line but now we see Maxine go to a
Petrov wow this is a Maxime we have
never seen before like he always plays
the same line over and over again trying
to bash his head against the proverbial
wall and here he plays a Petra of
showcasing a new opening repertoire and
perhaps a new Maxine Russia lagrav
yeah incredible and he's pulling a Yana
palmishi who had kind of a similar
transition he was a night off lifer and
then suddenly starts playing the Patcher
I mean everybody's playing the pet shop
now and I think part of the reason
Robert that the Petrov is such an
approachable opening is because it's
very concrete you don't really need to
learn a lot about Pawn structures uh
it's it's it's very Theory heavy and you
can really learn it in a couple of days
of very intensive studies so we've seen
all of these top players incorporate the
Petrov in their repertoire now mvl is
next and now I'm thinking of the game
between report and diplomacy from the
candidates where a report went into a
losing variations oh yeah Chagrin of all
the other candidate contestants Queen B3
here it comes following the line right
Queen E7 C5 and if Bishop C7 the pawn on
B7 is defended tactically because the
bishop takes H2 checks always important
to look if pieces are in a row with each
other is there a discovery here the
answer is definitely yes does Wesley
remember that game you think is he
thinking wait a second did I just walk
into the report line Wesley for sure
remembers that game after you know
working with the team at the Olympia
just speaking chess with all of them
Wesley has a great memory he focuses on
all the top level events I mean who
couldn't be watching the candidates uh
so yeah he certainly remembers in Knight
H4 and queen C2 maybe there's a knight
C3 in the future uh the Knight on H4
looks a little offside Donya but well
maybe eventually go to the F5 Square
it's preventing the Bishop from from
reaching F5 adding more strain on the
Knight on e4 now rarely in these
positions do you gobble up the pawn with
Bishop takes C4 and Rook takes E4 and
now that's not even an option after F5
right and so f i play to reinforce that
Knight and one thing to consider for
white is can I play G3 Knight G2 and put
a piece on F4 if you could play G3 and
Knight G2 in one Fell Swoop it would be
great for white but if you played G3 now
it's an F4 from black is on the table
and that looks actually quite
intimidating yeah these positions are
always terrifying to me I feel like
black is the one having all the fun
white might have some positional assets
you've got the E5 Square you've got a
you know nice looking pair of Pawns in
the center but black is solid as a rock
I'll also point out that F3 I don't even
want to calculate it or really even talk
about it because this move looks pretty
Unthinkable to me which is probably why
he's about to play it yeah I think
Fabiano against the palmistry played
something like F3 like Bishop E7 G3
there was some game uh in the Kenneth
that was like that I don't know if you
remember that one specifically done yet
but it was a game where Fabiano actually
uh had a huge lead in The Clock was in
his preparation and then unfortunately I
couldn't find it and then allowed the
draw yep and then they went into some
end game I remember it now
so I think though with proper play like
if you're not surprised by it black
should be okay in these positions and he
starts with G3 does Wesley so but look
at the evaluation bar Daniel I I was
saying maybe there's an F4 here and I'm
wondering if that's why the eval bar
prefers black yeah it was a good call
but maybe not the best move and the
opportunity train is going to pass so if
you're not playing F4 now then well
maybe you're playing another next move
because Knight A6 throughout the night
before but he goes for a different
approach he trades on C4
and what do we make of this this looks a
lot more tame and now I can develop the
Knight to C3 and it looks like White's
king is not really in danger anymore the
king is not in danger the D4 Pawn though
a long-term potential weakness uh
capablanca love playing against those
iqps in the end game has many amazing
wins in the end game and with Knight
coming to C7 eventually that pawn it's
not going to be traded off from D4 and
that could be really bad news for white
yeah it definitely could be Rook a to E8
bringing the last piece into the game it
just seems like Black's position is a
lot easier to play even if objectively
we're closer to equality than anything
else and maybe if you're Wesley you're
trying to get pieces off the board maybe
it's time for Knight G2 and Bishop F4
just trying to release the tension a
little bit further he's down an entire
two minutes on the clock as he grabs the
Knight on e4 another committal decision
how is he gonna follow this up yeah
opening the file looks very scary not
just the f file but also the C8 H3
diagonal here comes that Queen up to G4
H3 as you're highlighting a rook lift
could potentially be in the cards but
the good news for black uh is that
everything's open your king is safe your
opponents isn't the good news if there
is any for white is many of the black
pieces are restrained the 996 not going
anywhere useful just yet maybe c75 but
that still doesn't threaten anything
concrete the bishop on D6 staring into a
brick wall on G3 and H2 so look at this
a trade of pieces black maybe is a bit
better but there are no checkmating
threads no it seems like the worst is
behind him Wesley has to continue
treading carefully because all it takes
is allowing let's say G5 and then the
Knight drops back into D5 so you have to
keep your foot on the gas pedal if
you're Wesley I was thinking about going
Queen C5 but that would have been met
with Knight D5 and he might have just
walked into that exact line what if G5
here well G5 kicking the Knight the
Knight D5 with Tempo is your yeah
highlight there that looks very
promising uh for black and so you could
also bring that Knight to E6 to go after
the D4 Pawn oh yeah but then the E4 Pawn
is loose so there are tactics to figure
out here but it's clear that black is in
the driver's seat and there's a cool
line if we if we pull up an analysis
word real fast I I think MBL is going to
go G5 and we're gonna get this position
now Knight D5 is very tempting but you
brought up 96 which I really like go
after the weak pawn and after The Rook
takes C4 it's important to point out
that black has this shot Knight takes D4
using the pin using the fact that the
queen is hanging and white does not get
two Rooks for the queen because the
other heavy pieces are connected and on
the basis of this line he's played G5
wow and then he goes Knight D5 quickly
back in that line you were just showing
Dunya after Knight E6 instead of uh
Brooke takes E4 Queen E4 is actually
Checkmate because Queen F2 Queen F1
beautiful I love this mating
construction with the Knight on G2
covering the Luft Square
yeah very sad pony nice to not belong on
the fiancado Square but that's not a
here nor there because there's a queen
on H3 is a knight on G2 hello Rook H6
and H2 is falling hello Rook H6 coming
to a theater near you Wesley might have
made a mistake there with his last move
I think he just totally forgot about
this idea and the real hero of this
attack Robert is the Pawn on G5 look at
how it is restricting not just the
Knight on G2 but also the Rook on e4
preventing it from moving to H4 I think
Maxime is a couple accurate moves away
from finishing off this attack maybe
even Knight F4 that's exactly what I was
about to ask you is there Knight F4 here
uh where if you take you open up the G
file uh the King on G1 is really exposed
and getting checkmated so Knight F4 I
think White's best is to not capture it
but that just doesn't look Pleasant the
night could hop into D3 next there's
still threats on the G2 Square uh but
Wesley's shaking his head but he's gonna
put up that stubborn defense well Knight
F4 Rook D2 there's just Rook E6 to H6
and if you return to F1 with your knight
you get checkmated on G2 there's too
many squares to keep track of and MBL
just Exquisite calculation he doesn't
miss Moves Like These no know he does
not a GF GF there's going to be a rook
GA check and a queen F3 Checkmate to
follow so that looks highly unpleasant
what move does white even have here
because it's not like it's completely
lost maybe there's like a queen C5 just
like attacking some of Black's pieces
and that's a common idea right black has
invested himself fully in the attack and
he's left his backside a little bit
exposed so Queen C5 attacks The Rook on
f8 with Checkmate and then maybe a quick
D5 after that but Wesley sort of
cooperates with Rook D2 and what is he
planning on Rook H6 oh it's F3 a good
move though can you just oh if you take
maybe there is time for GTX F4 it's
something that needs to be calculated
here because EF gf4 GF for me the Knight
goes back to F1 and it could just be
winning for black I think it is just
winning for black but at least there's
some hope for Wesley as he dips around
30 seconds oh absolutely but this is
where mbl's phenomenal time management
you know really uh shines through he's
got 90 seconds plus to figure this out
and he doesn't even need them okay he's
played it and he's gone Knight C4
where's the mate
or is there a mate wow I think he
expected Knight F1 like I did and then
he would put both your Rooks in the G
file and third Rook G1 Checkmate but
with the Knight out in the open The Rook
on E1 actually covers the G1 Square in
the event of Rook G6 and Rook Jade and
Dania not only is they're not a mate
white could just turn this thing around
in a couple moves and win 100 all he
needs is like two moves 95 King H1 and
if you want to hear something crazy uh
Robert in this position the eval bar
originally was saying black is winning
but it reconsidered and now it's saying
the position is equal Wesley out thought
the engine here and black just has no
clear follow-up you can give one check
on the G file that's all you got King H1
Rook G2 white starts checking on the
eighth Rank and there's total
pandemonium white could win this 100
wow this is bad news for Maxine versus a
two-point lead and this is actually one
of our more double edged positions of
the day it feels like both players
they've been in control in throughout
different aspects of these positions but
right now now it is a toss-up Brooke
wrong move as you said back rank
problems night incomes
95 maybe was the move here Rook G2 and
queen E5 check I think is going to be a
Perpetual on E8 or and E5 I think that's
how the game is going to end and I think
Maxine is saved by Wesley's clock but
look at his Queen G4 maybe right on G1
whoa what is H3 Queen takes H3 Rook H2
where's the mate where maybe you start
with Queen can you play F2 oh my God
Queen takes H3 F2 and Rook G1 he took oh
it's mate oh it's simply Checkmate oh
it's just a ladder mate oh my God we all
missed it including Wesley so yeah but
the one person who doesn't miss it is
the person with a three-point lead
Maxine Russell Grove is on fire right
now despite miscalculating a little
something there he wins the game and
extends the lead holy smokes that was
simpler than I anticipated and that move
H3 Wesley kind of losing his mind there
but listen when you keep your foot on
the gas pedal for the entire game even
the greats eventually go wrong and mvl
steals it he was even losing at one
point there for a short while Robert
what a game what a topsy-turvy tactical
Affair that was and another Heartbreaker
for Wesley here in the early going of
the match and if this match continues
the way it has been that could be the
deciding game in a sense because Wesley
if he played properly with that
complicated position he could have cut
the lead in half down to one now it's
ballooned to three but we're back in a
Berlin Wesley so with the black pieces
and here he's played C5 his Bishop can
get to C6 as King go to B7 all the
standard Berlin fair but the reason why
I like this from White's perspective is
the space you have and I feel like
Maxine versus lagrav doesn't care what
the engine may say at the moment he has
that understanding and it's his comfort
zone
yeah but playing the Berlin sometimes
feels like driving a bus I don't know
what it's like to drive a bus I don't
think I ever will but it's just hard to
maneuver it around the tight Corners
right it's very unwieldy because there's
a lot of tactics that you're constantly
having to monitor for example King B7
was into Knight takes B6 you play a Miss
time G5 you run into E6 so you got to
keep track of a lot at the same time but
Wesley is a specialist and he doesn't
blunder one move tactics so other than
Queen takes H2 and Rook H6 that was
shocking I think we both trusted Wesley
you know he wouldn't oh totally like
that and here he played C4 and the white
Pawn on B3 Frozen in place if you took
on C4 the A4 Pawn would have dropped
that's not a pawn you can afford to lose
so I'm starting to like the outlook for
black but as you're highlighting here a
single move or two could really shatter
Black's hopes I mean E6 opening up the
bishop B2 looks very strong it also
frees that Knight and F4
um I don't know Dania but all of a
sudden I'm a little bit worried about
the immediate position for Wesley but I
like his long-term chances I'm trying to
figure out what exactly he's planning on
E6 and I think MBL is trying to figure
out the same thing it might be as simple
as just Bishop takes F3 GF and something
like Bishop to D6 but you can see why
I'm a little bit reticent here I mean a
lot of moving parts for black E6 is on
the board and the Evo bar is just
laughing in our face in an mvl's face
saying this is good for Wesley and
Bishop takes F3 looks like a very good
start I mean you could even take on F3
and take on E6 and just be like all
right your king is open your Pawn
structure is bad so I like your line
with taking F3 Bishop D6 but my point is
that even if you take on E6 the Knight
gets into E6 it's not the end of the
world
yeah Bishop F3 GF Bishop D6 why does
this weird counter-attacking move Rook
D5 hitting the Knight on F5 but that
night always in the Berlin has this H4
square that it can jump into okay Wesley
starts with C takes B3 who does this
favor and why Robert there's also Knight
E5 which can be thrown in with absolute
pandemonium oh my gosh 95 bc2 Knight
takes C6 even
some of these positions it's getting
wild but I would be really nervous to
give up that C2 Pawn he's not though he
takes it F7 I'll have a pass Pawn on my
own and the knight's about to go to G6
which wins material that's a huge move
otherwise Rook C1 Bishop takes A4 black
is up 8 000 pawns on the queen side but
Knight G6 strikes with devastating
effect winning either The Rook or the
bishop or both and he plays Rook D2
trying to keep his Rook involved in the
fight while attacking C2 I dislike
Wesley's decision to go for this line I
thought Bishop D6 was a clear advantage
and what's he gonna do now because
Knight G6 is such a vicious threat there
could be something with Bishop B4 Knight
Jesus king B7 uh something of that sort
but instead he just goes Rook takes C2
okay what now can take on A4 Maybe
yeah then I guess why it's gonna go Rook
to E2 for instance maybe then five oh
there's also a pen geez yeah so much is
happening here
yeah maybe this is gonna work out for
Wesley I mean
he's taking his time is there another
candidate move here I guess the
immediate King B7 does run into Rook F
to C1 and you don't want to allow Rook
takes C7 with check definitely not and
maybe bishop A4 there's Rook C4
threading Rook takes B4 in some
positions and Knight G6 I mean this is
really messy yeah and this is where
you're just happy it's five plus one and
not like imagine having this position in
a bullet game no you just lose like
three two you lose with both colors like
it's zero zero I resign on the spot uh
but here here I like the look of Rook C4
I don't know if it's actually good but
uh it does threaten Rook takes Bishop he
goes Rook C1 and now that's giving black
the time he needs to say I have how many
extra pawns on the queen side if my math
is right that's three pawns that are
gonna barrel down the queen side yeah
Wesley has to try to get the upper hand
here he's down by three points he's got
a chance
let's see if he can keep his composure
an out dual mvl in the super chaotic
position Knight jumps into E5 White's
got one Pawn he's got to keep that pawn
at all costs right you can't just pivot
away for nothing an mvl sinking his
teeth into these juicy Central squares
it should be three Knight G6 will be my
Rook takes F7 in exchange sacrifice
because of the c b and a pawns that are
gonna Rumble down the board so white
will have an extra opponent on the king
side and a rook black will have a bishop
and three extra Pawns of the queen side
this looks amazing for Wes and Robert
phenomenal composure by Mr so to play
Bishop B3 this is the kind of move we
take for granted but the wherewithal to
realize hey I'm gonna sack my exchange
for F7 and I've got these three passers
that stuff which is not easy to
determine in a classical game and Wesley
figures it out instantly looks like
mvl's initiative is the first to start
fizzling out
and look at Max Team he's steals plenty
of time on the clock here he's been
ahead in most these games against Wesley
but Wesley playing Perfect Defense and
now turning it into offense Rook takes
F7 seems fairly obvious is there some
kind of drawback that I'm not
considering
um or an alternative I don't see it I
mean the only alternative is I see is
King B7 but why would you sack your
exchange and leave the F Bond alive okay
he just double checked it and it's far
from over White's pieces are still
running amok the Knight is moving into
C6 you could easily lose control of this
if you're Wesley you've got to push your
pawns with the utmost caution here
that's right and I think he wants a king
B7 Pawn C5 Pawn A4 he's gonna move the
pieces together but let's not forget
White's extra Pawn on the king side and
not to mention this Pawn on G7 there's a
bishop on B2 so if you're not looking
out carefully if you get hit with the G4
and a night move and G7 drops all of a
sudden white also has past pawns running
up the board but Bishop C3 played by
Maxime he wants to trade Bishops and get
another Rook to the C file but that
caught me by surprise I must admit I
think it's an interesting practical try
once again the eval bar is not happy but
what you want to do in your opponent's
time pressure is pose as many dilemmas
as possible you want to confront your
opponent with a bunch bunch of decisions
that increases the possibility and the
probability of a mistake and of acute
time pressure so let's see how mvl
handles the defensive task okay Bishop
slides back in here comes the Apon the a
pawn can go up the board but the Rook is
not well placed oh good idea
is loose that would drop off like a fly
do not blunder Rook takes B3 you have to
move your Bishop where do you put it
Bishop D5 Bishop C2 the issue is that
the bishop doesn't have any anchored
squares so if the King was on B7 and you
would play A4 I think then the game
would largely be over that's right but
uh you're not getting a square that you
feel quite safe on and G4 at any moment
can happen that Knight would love to
move to a square like C4 to attack the
bishop and D6
um Bishop D5 looks good Rook D1 seems
logical
yeah just keep pursuing keep chasing and
there could be a moment where there's an
exchange Sacrifice from white but I
don't think Wesley wants to draw but
he's now down under 40 seconds he drops
the bishop all the way back to Jade he's
clearly playing for a win yeah and he is
and he has to right given the situation
and the match and the fact that he's got
three connected passers on the queen
side it would be a crying shame to give
up a draw in this position and now mvl
has to find a spicy move maybe F4 maybe
your move G4 although I guess playing it
here doesn't really have the same effect
after Knight H4 right so watch out for
forks with Bishop E5 and Knight F3 check
to follow so you're right that maybe F4
is the leave at that point he does let's
go G4 but it not approved it by the
engine and watch out for Bishop takes E5
F4 I think you have to play F4 here and
he does G5 there it is strikes a dagger
and if you take you blunder into Bishop
takes E5 and Knight F3 chick now maybe
it's so desperate spirit that you
actually want to play FG and then G
takes H6 at the end Robert but this is
kind of frivolous yeah because black is
those three pawns on the queen side and
two minor pieces for Rook Rook F1
defending the F3 Square most importantly
and the simple King B7 so calm and now
he's gonna bring his Rook into the
center and maybe even go for checkmate
with rookie too that's a possibility yes
Bishop D5 with like Bishop C5 check at
some point as well
G1 not safe in the slightest yeah I
didn't anticipate this now White's
gotten everything he wants nominally
Robert he's gotten the protected passer
on the king side but it has come at a
great cost as king is super weak but
Wesley down to 20 seconds the game is
far from over maybe NBL should just push
F6 yeah I like it and I think that the
points Bishop E5 Bishop native to check
there's Rook takes F3 I've got opposite
colored Bishops but with the pass Pawn
on the f file it might give just enough
compensation for the material deficit so
F6 here it goes Wesley shakes his head
uh-oh he's trying to figure it out under
now 17 16 15 seconds done yeah he does
not have a lot of time he he's going for
that line Knight F3 check but this is
actually a three result game Rook D7
check and F7 and white threatens Bishop
G7 Robert it's a miracle the black as
Bishop D5 and he can give the bishop
away for the pawn but White's hunting
for those King side Pawns in the
resulting position I think white might
have the upper hand now I agree Bishop
G7 forces what's she waiting for and
then you could even think about just
running those beep beep whoa whoa whoa
whoa no no this can't be right no
there's a deep on there's a deep on but
mvl thinks that he can collect the pawns
and promote and stop black spawns all
with enough time to spare he wants H4
and a new queen of his own okay he gets
that Queen but we see a swap and now
it's time for five yeah King B5 and then
you can go A4 H3 but you need
it's a pawn race which Pawn do you push
if you're Wesley I have no one second oh
I barely got to move off oh my gosh he's
little HC A3 g682
and G6 A2 Bishop G7 blockates the blind
whoa what a move King C4 he doesn't even
want to promote just yet because G7 now
A2 the bishop needs the G7 Square as
well and if Bishop G7 then you push the
beep on blacks in time and this should
be a draw oh my goodness but still a
three result game because oh yeah if
white tries too hard that B and D Pawn
could be dangerous but I think the
king's escaping up to H5 uh-oh and
Bishop G7 Bishop G7 stops the pawn I
think White's out of danger but black
has Perpetual black must have Perpetual
here King G6 there's Queen zero King F7
where's the check
[Music]
goodness there are no more checks
Bishop F6 is B2 potentially to be a
little nervous about that Queen C8 check
wins the game oh because king queen C3
Queen missed it he missed it and queen
B2 what do we get the trailer I think
the queen at the same time no he's going
the wrong way King A2 and now it's a
game again oh oh
my gosh both players make mistakes here
no Queen takes D4 was winning and this
is really bad for Black second Queen
[Laughter]
Queen A5 the second Queen A5 it's made
mate oh my God oh my gosh two games in a
row where Maxima Sheila grave does a
ladder Checkmate and Wesley so must be
beside himself it doesn't look like it I
mean the guy just doesn't react at least
not outwardly but that was hectic
what did we just see
holy smokes that was crazy and I guess
mvl's decision
to give up The Rook for the Bishop
Robert I was super skeptical I thought
Black's pawns were way faster but he
realized that that breakthrough with H4
that was coming super fast in his own
right and dodging all of Wesley's checks
major kudos to mvl for that hard to
fault Wesley so when you have no time in
your clock figure out which Pawn to push
when you have three runners that's
immensely difficult so I don't really
fault him there but Maxine vasilograph
he benefits from his Superior time
management and we get into this position
where things are a little bit weird uh
you can just trade on these Bishop takes
D6 and the Knight on E6 is kind of
misplaced because it's in the bishop on
ch's path so I know it's hard to catch
our breaths and go into the next game
but Donna Wesley needs to win this game
I know some people might get annoyed at
me for this but I just want to rewind
really quickly and show the point of
Knight c6s this is important it looks
like a blunder but it's actually a super
old move
it looks like it blenders a piece two
different ways Bishop takes E4 there's
D5 Bishop D3 E4 wins the piece back you
can also try the move D5 and this also
looks like it wins a piece but here
black has Knight back to C5 DC and again
E4 picks up the piece so this has been
known for well over 20 years but it's
considered to be better for white let's
go back now to the live position because
Wesley has castled Queen side and
sacrificed upon that's right you know
with the pawn uh there on E5 earlier he
ended up giving it up sorry I should say
and now he's just saying I'm gonna plant
my pieces in front of that pawn because
the bishop and D6 it's not very active
if you ever play F5 for black maybe
you're striking at the 94 but you're
also opening up your king so it's a big
moment for white do you allow F5 do you
stop F I'm playing G4 yourself so I
think that West is a lot to figure out
she sinks in his chair and the typical
chess player right just so focused in
the game that you lose sight of the
camera
yeah yeah the forehead cam the side face
cam you know all sorts of cams but this
this might not be firing on all
cylinders as Wesley had hoped I mean
there's a second H7 but it doesn't work
out Queen H5 that's not Checkmate
because the Knight on E6 is blocking the
Bishop's control over G8 that's right so
the Knight drops back to E4 and now the
question is did playing F6 help or hurt
black you kick back this knight from G5
but you expose the A2 to G8 diagonals
you were just saying that might mean
that the black king is in grave danger
in some tactical sequences now Knight D4
played by Maxine this is something that
strong players do when they're up
material but facing some pressure they
give that material back saying at least
my moves become easier but Dania after
Bishop D4 e takes D4 I'm already looking
at just maybe even a take taking on D6
bring your pieces towards the center and
I feel like white even though there
might be a one Pawn deficit has the game
plan of I'm gonna get all the activity
the position offers yeah and you could
get into some sort of end game Knight D6
Queen D6 there's the move Queen F3 to D5
uh trying to get the Queens off the
board and get the bishop on an optimal
square instead Rook H to E1 so Wesley
has completely shifted his attention
from the King side to the center but how
is he going to get rid of this very
powerful defensive Bishop on E5
yeah I don't think he's the time to play
G3 move the queen and play Pawn to F4
that seems to be way too maybe oh my
gosh no way he's doing it I was just
saying that's too time consuming and he
goes right for it and the bishop on E5
it is a bit awkward because it doesn't
have many squares and if F4 happens The
Rook on E1 is happy to see the queen on
E7 yeah this is incredibly time
consuming and he's gonna go Queen D3 so
that after F4 Bishop D6 he has the
threat of Knight G5 uh aiming at H7 but
I'm definitely skeptical
but I'm gonna let mvl figure out exactly
why I'm skeptical I don't know precisely
what black should do here we use the
term time consuming for the position but
something that Maxime has done really
well is he keeps the lead on the clock
and consumes time when the position gets
complicated so it seems like he's well
prepared today he's confident he's
trusting his instincts and then when the
position gets a bit messy and he's going
to make a move like Queen to B4 leaving
uh the king side altogether he sent your
Bishop on C4 is under attack maybe this
Rook on E1 is a bit loose that's
actually something that should not be
overlooked that at some moment you may
give up the D4 pawn and it can't be
captured because the Rook on E1 is in
the Queen's sight anytime two pieces are
making contact that's a source of
tactics that's something you have to
notice so absolutely true and now white
has a major fork in the road Bishop B3
and Bishop D3 were the main options he
sticks to this diagonal Robert so he's
trying maybe to keep the king confined
maybe set up some sort of Knight G5
tricks but I'm I'm still skeptical I
still don't see it after Bishop D7 it's
about time to play Bishop D7 and it's
also important Knight G5 won't work
anyway because the queen on before
defended The Rook on f8 so everything
was held together for the moment Bishop
D7 tried to play Bishop C6 uh you don't
actually want to take the Knight E4
because if you get all the light squares
you may eventually come under Fire right
obstacle Bishops don't just mean a draw
it might mean that you're getting under
attack and you can't Parry off the
threats and mvl continuing to play Fast
he has this position under control
and Wesley's down to two minutes so this
is very likely to be the last game of
the five minute segment another loss for
Wesley would balloon the lead up to Five
Points Robert so this is actually
pivotal this is a pivotal game for
Wesley at the very least to make a draw
and stabilize he goes Queen H5 just
trying to create some threats uh not
allow this bishop to come to F5 for
example if the queen are going to D3 so
here the queen of H5 Bishop E8 is a
possibility if you want to just kick the
queen out of there but maybe it's not
necessary because what is White's
follow-up the answer is F2 to F4 how
threatening it is is a different
question than what is on tap oh for sure
and mvl taking a slightly longer think
here a lot of moving parts that he has
to keep track of in the center and on
the king side
and what comes to mind other than Bishop
E8 here I guess you can bring the Rook
into the game but then that allows F4 a
most thing about D3 honestly like oh and
just trying to open the position up for
the bishop pair and if Rook takes D3 the
B2 Pawn is a little bit loose in some
positions I could just go Bishop E6 for
example maybe even sacrifice that
because the B2 Pawn is hanging instead
he goes Rook to E8 allowing F4 is he
just gonna retrieve his Bishop to D6
Diane I think that's very likely unless
he has some sort of wild tactic cooked
up with D3 but I really don't see that
working you could just grab the bishop
yeah I think he just wants Bishop D6 and
he's saying come at me bro
okay well Bishop F7 and G6 looks a bit
scary at first glance we're just trying
to go for checkmate so I don't know what
his exact reply is that oh yeah well
rookie seven Bishop G6 H6 maybe I know
but what's the follow-up for white there
I agree with the sound effects maybe
just Knight takes D6 in that position I
real and then try to bring the bishop
back from G6 and put a queen on that
square the thing about that position as
you're indicating right there is that
you'll likely win the D4 upon back and
even if it's the material is level black
is in big trouble because your king is
stuck in the corner and so white will be
much more active so now all of a sudden
deep in thought is Maxine vasilograph
maybe I'll play Rook d8 instead of
rookie seven but I don't think it
matters Bishop G6 is borderline
pre-movable and eight shifts will be the
follow-up and that looks very scary as
now Maxine Russell he's dipping close to
Wesley so's time for the first time this
game I was briefly flirting with Bishop
G4 but there's no way that works because
after Queen G4 work I've found and you
were having major background problems in
just 1966 ended the game there rookie 7
played after a long time and a sacrifice
on F6 whoa before whoa that was
unbelievable the point everybody we
could bring up an announcement quickly
was that Bishop takes E7 a move ago and
the same thing now is met by Bishop G6
and mate on H7 it's Unstoppable this
play where they were I mean Maxine saw
this he pre-moves gf6 maybe he should
have thought because my God
I'm sorry to interrupt you Robert Bishop
takes F4 was the only move it was the
only move and queen takes F6 he forgot
that the queen could capture the Knight
but that was so hard to see and now it's
over I think after Bishop G6
let's go back to the live board
he's just down in exchange he gave up
The Rook on F7 because otherwise it was
Checkmate and Bishop takes D1 is still
met by Bishop G6 you don't even take the
bishop oh my God and D3 an attempt to
muddy The Waters by MBL but I think just
well Rook takes D3 Queen G1 that's his
idea a brilliant defensive move D3 but
can you play Bishop G6 anyway yes
because there's no threat and there's no
checkmating threat so Bishop G6 played
and if the king and Bishop takes C2 at
the end yeah that's crucial
will MBL resign or will he bleed out the
rest of the match clock
I feel like based on his play this far
he might want another game in the five
plus one but also a three-point lead is
definitely sufficient so if you're
maximum you probably just keep playing
for a few more moves and we have just
about 20 seconds left in the five plus
one this is
he might not and DC Bishop takes C2 F5
and Rook d8 check oh forces the mate
that's so nasty and it is gonna be the
last game of the segment it is going to
be the last game
even if it results in made and it's
Bishop H7 with mate come on Wesley the
queen G6
Queen G6 and The Bishop's hanging on G4
measure oh King E6 Bishop G8 mate oh my
God or queen she gave me that is nasty
so Wesley so takes this final game of
the five plus one he can be feeling a
little bit better about himself I'm sure
he's disappointed with the current score
uh but Donya that was an impressive
attacking display oh that was amazing
and that was some spicy tactical play he
didn't lose his composure down a pawn in
a situation where it looked like his
attack was fizzling out Robert he just
hunkered down and he won a big one and
now the lead is far more manageable it
certainly is Wesley silver gaining some
of that confidence as he heads into the
three plus one and we're heading into
one of the most fun stretches of the
year the speechless Championship will be
finalized the winner will be known in
about a week and also happening in just
about a week is the state of Chess get
ready for the Q4 2022 state of chess.com
I'm coming to you live on December 21st
we have some huge news for the chess
community and the event will be followed
by Community Q a with Danny wrench plus
some very special guests will be joining
the show to talk about the exciting
announcements we're making and what
these announcements mean for the future
of the chess Community don't miss the
show December 21st at 10 A.M Pacific
Time right here on twitch.tv chess and
don't miss this show that we have right
now we'll return shortly for the three
plus one time segment of this match here
in the quarterfinals of speeches
championship between Wesley so and
Maxine Russia legrall
foreign
[Music]
ER Danny wrench Chief chess officer back
again with more chess terms here for you
today we're going to talk about the past
Pawn the past Pawn must be pushed you
hear it said often and that's because
just about every end game you see that
isn't a blowout often comes down to
maybe someone's up one Pawn or maybe
even just the first person to create a
past Pawn is the person who goes on to
win that game we're going to talk about
what the past Pawn is and to find it for
you in today's video let's do it what is
a past Pawn a past Pawn is a pawn that
has no enemy pawns stopping it from
moving forward that means pawns either
on the file in which it resides or on
the adjacent files that would therefore
capture the pawn should it advance so if
a pawn has none of those things stopping
its way then it's time to push them baby
as our boy Yasser would say it as you
hear mentioned on many broadcasts that
you would watch on chess TV and on that
note as we look at our game examples we
like to do this is taken from Thomas
chefsky versus rajaba here white plays
the move beef on 5x Glam which
highlights again it's not how many pawns
you have but who's going to be
threatening to get a queen first after
black takes it white pushes forward with
gusto and because the Rook can't
blockade the pawn due to the light
Square Bishop this game is already over
black is going to have to sacrifice the
bishop for the pawn on B6 and white
would simply be up a minor piece note
that after the first move B5 should a
takes B5 have been played white would
have pushed this pawn and then trap The
Rook on A7 showing the power of the pass
Pawn as with it protecting the bishop
this Rook is completely out of the game
and white would easily go on to win
picking up pawns and just flexing the
rook's muscles over the bishop for the
rest of the game so here we see a pass
Plum being used as a weapon to just
cramp down and trap all of your enemy
pieces so this has been another chest
terms video hope you enjoyed it hope
you're enjoying all of them and with
that I will sign off hoping that you
learned something about what a pass Pawn
is and we'll see you around on chess.com
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
a storm is brewing Dimitri on Jacob the
Drake is a wizard within the Tempest the
best have come to test their skills and
brave the storm
oh we missed it oh
oh my goodness the wheels the wheels
have come out that could be the magic
for some this is familiar ground oh my
goodness Knight d8 whoa
oh my God what a tactic
this is insane oh look at Fabby
exhausting every last resource the the
battles will be electricity
the moves will be fast it's game over
it's winning oh my God he's gonna make a
queen the stakes will be high he just
grabs his head he can't believe it he
just gave away the pawn the 2022 speed
Chess Championship is now
fasten your speed belts my friends we're
in for a wild ride
and we are back here at the speed Chess
Championship the last quarter-final
matchup between Maxine versus the grave
and Wesley so is finished with the five
minute time control Donya we've seen
Maxime jet out to a 6-3 lead what does
Wesley have to do differently in order
to cut into this lead and maybe overtake
Maxine nothing I actually think Wesley's
playing just fine I mean we might see
some changes in the opening maybe he
needs to speed up a little bit in the
early middle game because he has been
falling behind on the clock consistently
but largely Wesley just needs to play
the same way that he just played that
last Berlin game that that was sharp
that was tactically created wait what
nope was it the Petrov why am I blanking
what opening was their last game their
last game can you remember
no I can't remember I don't know what
you just did to me you incepted like a
lot what did you do to me I can always
remember the opening whatever that was
Wesley needs to play the same way fast
calm compost and most importantly
sharpen the Tactical face
well we saw the smartest stats at the
start of the match it was four and a
half four and F was the prediction in
the longest time Patrol that was wrong
six to three and Max seems favor and if
the rest of his predictions are to be
believed Maxime is the favorite in the
shorter time controls as well that would
Bode terribly for Wesley so Dania what
do you think now that we're in more
familiar time zones time controls I
should say three plus one Maxime Wesley
they're Veterans of all type patrols but
title Tuesday isn't three plus one do
you think that Wesley now that he's in
the shorter time Patrol maybe he'll
actually speed up as we've seen players
do before well nanuka has the real
advice in the chat Wesley hired Dania as
her coach yes maybe I should just
replace him I mean I really would
totally do better against an on form mvl
but three plus one that is a Time
control Wesley greatly enjoyed enjoys
he's improved a lot in three plus zero
Robert and that one second increment
obviously only plays into his hands
certainly does and Maxim he's busy
drinking
[Music]
she has a feet
and he's feasting on Wesley so at least
he was before that ninth game because I
think that was important for Wesley no
matter what the opening was Maxime had
been in firm control winning a game with
Four Queens on the board checkmating
Wesley twice in a row along the final
column right in the the a file in the
Queens game the H file when he
sacrificed his Queen and had the two
Rooks on the h g file so I think that
Wesley he can calm down a little bit
having won that latest game I'll be
totally honest I didn't really hear a
word you just said because I was
mesmerized by just the sight of mvl
vigorously chewing whatever's on his
desk
and for some reason it reminded me of
the show Comedians and Cars Getting
Coffee there should be another show
Grand Masters at their desk eating
snacks
I guess with Jerry Seinfeld also host
that one or who do you have in mind
perhaps I I I've never seen Seinfeld but
I've heard good things about him
uh well you know we've heard good things
about this format this event just a
reminder I knew you'd find a way to turn
that into what you were about to say you
know sometimes you got to do what you
got to do and what these players have to
do is get ready for a shorter time
control because they have an hour of
three minute plus one second increment
so to remind everybody we just had an
hour and a half of the longest time
Patrol now we're getting into an hour of
three plus one that's more at home for
these players they play this time
between title Tuesdays every week or
twice a week because they're two every
Tuesday and then finally we will have
bullets so Donya I guess you said
beforehand you weren't going to make any
predictions you're gonna be neutral I'm
still asking you to be neutral but who
do you see as the favorite when the
waning seconds remain on the clock I
think so far I'd have to go with MBL and
it's not because Wesley loses his
composure I just feel like Wesley makes
uh more blunders in the time scramble
phase or at least it's been the case so
far I mean I'm really impressed by mvl's
level of tactical sharpness thus far in
the match which is why I really think
time management is going to be crucial
in the three plus one can Wesley avoid
spending a lot of time in the opening
you know what kind of preparation is he
going to bring to the table in the three
plus one largely though Robert I'm
stalling because I really think they're
so evenly matched that it's just hard to
point out where one player is better
than the other because both of them
share a lot of characteristics including
their incredible composure and time
pressure it's true and well Wesley while
on break he could have ventured through
that library and found a chess book or
two maybe we'll help him with some of
these openings and the problem is
normally you know what to expect from
Maxine versus the grav here we have no
idea but we're off E4 from Maxime and
the chat believes that Maxim is the
favorite to win three plus one and are
we gonna get just another Berlin come on
play something please no Wesley come on
at least play yeah just place it keep
the Queens on the board do something
it's not rookie one again
we're getting the same thing and it
seems like Wesley finding this position
at least bearable from the black side
and here Maxime just doing the same old
same way now Maxim you better come up
with something because if you're just
gonna repeat that drawing game
I mean actually that might be exactly
what he's trying to do Robert he's up by
three points let's not forget that so
maybe a repeat of that game is kind of
what he's planning for well so far so
good if that's the case exactly the same
position nothing new
decision he is right we saw rookie eight
and queen said oh okay here we go first
Bishop B5 but you know you make that
sound but let's no no it's a good move
it's a great right because if you could
reduce C6 the bishop on B7 is bad and
the D6 Pawn is weak and this is how top
level Grand Masters win games and you
may say what happened nothing it's a one
move threat but what they do is they
cause their opponent problems and when
you continue to be a nuisance and you
have to spend time solving the new
issues in the position that's how Maxine
gets the upper hand already rookie a
check was a threat that's where the
queen slid over to f8 so the rook and
eight covers the square
and this bishop is a massive irritant
you pointed out something very important
a lot of people just go C6 oh you go C6
and rookie eight actually no you can't
because then you drop the pawn on D6 and
you blunt your own Bishop if you play A6
the bishop can actually sneak and
Slither into D7 in certain positions so
white actually has to set himself up for
A6 maybe a move like Queen C3 can be
considered although that does run into
the very nasty C5 not entirely sure
Robert how mvl tightens the screws here
well in that variation you're talking
about Queen G3 would be possible after a
C5 oh that gets messy very quickly until
he goes Queen E3 and how can you blame
him the only open file on the board is
the e-file white has an advantage I
don't care it says point two uh no
it's just a really annoying position so
what black really wants to accomplish
here is Bishop C6 and Rook T8 one of the
problems of playing Bishop C6 is the A6
Pawn becomes a bit loose so you have the
benefit of cover the E8 square but you
lose of A6 and I wonder if Maxime has a
move right here to take advantage of
like Queen H3 and C3 something of that
nature but he starts the queen H3 if G6
made Bishop H6 just cause problems left
and right poking and prodding and I
don't remember who shared the famous
advice about making 40 threats and
eventually your opponent is going to
blunder I think that was vastly Smith's
love or at least it's commonly
attributed to him and that's kind of
what mvl is doing just threat threat
threat threat and eventually you're
gonna make a concession actually rookie
8 here is not out of the question Robert
so wait a second rookie one you're
saying and Bishop to B5 but the problem
is after rookie hit the queen is kind of
Trapped you do have Bishop back to G7
though worst case scenario wow but this
is a difficult line to assess because
even the event of like a rook E3 type of
move the A6 Pawn is hanging so you have
to not just calculate oh can I give up
my queen for the back rank threat you to
recognize if all the major pieces get
off the board A6 is in trouble so here
we go rookie three take maybe Queen
takes and then there's Bishop D4 oh
you're getting all spicy now I'm getting
all Rebecca Harris on you here but let's
see Queen E3 there's also Queen C8 and
you know the issue is Bishop A6 Queen A6
Queen E8 is checkmate with one small
problem Bishop takes C8 that is true but
black is tied to the defensive not too
many pieces remaining which is why we
believe that black should be okay but
looking at the Times a minute 10 for
Wesley he's doing all right for now but
if that time gets cut in half then we're
going to start seeing some problems but
look at Maxime once again building a
lead in the clock and thinking in a
critical moment why was this moment
critical because Bishop takes D4 is
available to Black right now and now you
know the advantage actually is turning a
Black's favor well I think what Maxine
wants is Bishop fa Bishop B3 and another
counter Desperado Bishop T6 but guess
what here black has another Desperado
and When the Smoke Clears white actually
does take A6 he simply takes on D6 and
the worst is behind him I I really don't
think that white has anything here in
fact we're talking about an advantage
for black because Wesley is making
making a b line for the E5 score with
his King Here Comes The King and that's
bad news for Maxime he is much more
passive here and look at the queen side
pawns A5 B6 D6 dark squares your Bishop
can't touch this and so that's good news
for Wesley and Bishop comes to C4 to
attack F7 he wants to induce D5 to shut
the bishop down for now yeah you can't
touch this but white is hammering away
oh no oh Flex pawns and a draw agreed no
I was okay with the other one this one I
wanted to see play out yeah but the
problem with the draw agreement is that
you didn't hear my amazing reference
because of the draw for as I said he was
hammering home because I can't touch
this yes nice I missed it because I was
too busy being upset well I was upset
too I mean black had a free free hand
there didn't he I mean what was what
were we missing
probably nothing but this was the game
that was one yeah now
I recognize this this happened before I
wonder what they looked at during the
breakers this Knight D4 played earlier
this time remember the king went to Aha
that was a pawn F6 when Maxine played
Knight D4 so he looked into this line
plays Knight D4 earlier and I think this
is a bit of bad news for Wesley he
started thinking a little bit here so
I'm not sure if Wesley just trying to
remember or if he just didn't check this
in full detail but either way uh he
spent just just a little bit of
hesitation and that should be good news
for Maxime who according to the engine
has a bit of an advantage right now yeah
although looking at this position
visually it obviously is very scary but
gosh that Black Knight on D4 it lasted
less than than Lauren strand in the ring
but with the e-file wide open now I'm
terrified if I'm playing Black and
there's all sorts of cool tactics Robert
yeah you know what I'm thinking you know
me too well Queen H4 if we pull up an
analysis word real fast Knight D6 you
actually have Queen H6 Queen D6 here but
if you play CD if you play inconsciously
Queen F7 Rook F7 this is as old as the
hills and it's called Checkmate yes and
I've actually I think I've only had that
once in my career I've landed that exact
Checkmate but it is fun to uncork that
and wouldn't be fun for Maxine which is
why plays Bishop B4 going after the Rook
on E1 now Knight F6 is check opening up
The Rook to the queen on E7 but the
queen would take on F6 so that doesn't
work as a discovery tactic so instead
you have to find a move here do you play
rookie two that seems pretty
straightforward but then Queen takes H4
is perhaps an option uh you threaten
Bishop G4 after that and queen rook and
other Rook all in the same diagonal two
pawns down is Wesley so oh my God this
is what black is on such thin ice now it
should be pointed out that these Queen
F7 rookie 8 tactics are not going to
work as long as black has Bishop back to
f8 so you don't have to worry about that
in particular
and if you're white you got a lot of
things to worry about where is the
compensation for the two pawns Bishop G4
is now a massive threat Robert and as
impressive as this looks for white I
just don't see anything concrete maybe
you take on D4 and intend to meet Bishop
G4 with Queen G4 and Knight F6 right
just to trade off all the pieces and
then we get obstacles Bishops with the
safer King for white the extra Pawn at
least initially for black uh that's it
probably Dynamic equality but black does
have the advantage according to the
evaluation bar so there maybe is a queen
H1 check or queen H6 check something
other so I like Queen H6 because you
can't play King B1 then you get
background checkmated
Queen H6 King P1 and queen H1 is back
ring mate that makes sense so how does
white have to meet Queen H6 you have to
play rookie three that's awkward yeah
some kind of awkward move like rookie
three or Knight D2 or something of A
Sort but that's not what you want from
what you want to keep that Knight on e4
nice and active in the center not as
awkward as Danny wrench at a cocktail
party though
I forgot it's funny he's with an earshot
he is definitely nearby and I was just
at a you know the chess boxing after
party with him he wasn't awkward at all
people loved him in fact somebody even
tweeted about it so uh the jokes on you
this is not as awkward as Daniel
narrative he had a cocktail party now
that's accurate you know I I wasn't
gonna say it you know you're my friend
we hang out at cocktail party so if the
Rook on E3 now it's you'd love to get a
bishop C5 in but the 94 covers the
square but Bishop E6 just defensive play
from Maxime and it's a weak Pawn E6
Donya the Knight on e4 is superb so I
actually don't believe that black has an
advantage here but I also don't think
that white has too much going from
either yeah clearly white no longer has
an attack and the Rooks are they're
misplaced you have to be very careful if
blackplay is a sneaky little move like
Bishop A5 that threatens Bishop B6 and
if you move one Rook then the other
one's gonna get pinned so how is white
meeting Bishop A5 H3 ah and just so fast
Wesley thinking on his feet and solving
problems I think the worst is behind him
now I agree Bishop D4 Rook H6 gh6 or
this is much better because the pawn
structure is intact and the Knight on e4
would love to have upon F3 but the pawn
F3 isn't happy without opponent G2 as
well so Knight G5 go right after E6 Rook
a to E8 is met by Queen E4 as your point
E5 isn't it by Queen C4 so you have to
be careful like all sorts of nice
threats oh the knight in Queen combo I
mean it just whips up tactical threats
out of nowhere now you actually can play
rookie 8 and meet Queen F Queen E4 with
this move Rook to F5 intercepting the
queen and counter-attacking the Knight
maybe that's the way to go that's like
one of those lucky saves that you have
yeah they actually have their Queen E4
there's a rook takes F2 uh freeing the
f8 square for your king what a Fearless
move though by MPL giving up E6 with
check and saying hey I've got all the
lift I need on H7
oh gosh that's a little bit scary and
you know what he also might be
considering isn't sacrifice an exchange
sacrifice a queen E6 King h8 Knight F7
broke F7 and after the queen she's like
Bishop E5 and you just have everything
kind of under control I'm not building's
gonna go for it and he doesn't but Queen
E4 check picks up the bishop on D4 but
you're gonna lose your knight on F7 so
it's an equal trade of pieces which is
not good for white the two Rooks if they
can coordinate that's going to be bad in
the long term for now uh Wesley if you
wanted to draw Queenie fortra King G8
you could Desperado the Knight on H6 but
I really don't think that that's a way
to play for a win but mvl with G6 he
doesn't want his King to drop back to G8
white could still play Knight takes H6
here but then black can snapped the pawn
off on F2 and you have to watch for back
rig problems Rook a to E8 is also a
threat Robert I think Wesley might be
losing control of the game here are they
practically speaking white is lost
because look at the pawn structure F2
and H3 isolated and after Rook F7 other
Rook to f8 you're just gonna drop pawns
left in right so Wesley now dropping 24
seconds is Queen E7 going for an attack
there's Knight G5 double check don't go
rookie eighth there a very alert move by
mvl to intercept the the seventh Rank
and now he should bring his Rook into
the game is it Queen takes B7 rookie d8
maybe there and Rook AE it as well good
point you know just all sorts of threats
so he's not taking on B7 just yet
yes
the Knight can come back to C4 what a
wild position on majorities on either
side black has to hunt for the H3 Pawn
but Black's King is still very weak
there's Force Galore if you take on H3
Robert Queen C8 picks up the Rook that's
right in any position white has good
chances here that pawn on A6 could drop
if you play Knight B6 cutting off The
Rook from the pawn he does it right away
but there could be issues with the King
on B1 Rook d one check Rook F2 to follow
or Rook D2 in this case like chiseling
his way inside onto the second rank
hunting for white skin doubling on the
second rank white has to drop the Knight
back in that case two seconds for MBL
wow and Knight can go back to A4 it does
bad free move
he was expecting Knight C4 that's right
now he's just lost
six oh move the queen safely does in a
B4 is possible and King goes to B3 and
slides out Exquisite technique by Wesley
now his King is safe his Pawn is
rumbling forward toward promotion and he
can just go Knight C5 oh he could have
probably taken on E5 as well I think
yeah King B7 that's it Queen B8 even
wins yeah 96 there Knight A6 all of it
wins and that is a second victory in a
row uh and at least in decisive games
because the previous game was a draw but
a second decisive game going Wesley's
way is now a two-point deficit he's
probably feeling a lot better and we're
not feeling much better because we keep
seeing this line and Maxime is not
getting anything of note yeah back and
forth the pendulum swings an MBO I mean
now the ball is squarely in his court he
keeps repeating the same line banging
his head against the wall
and I think he really thinks that he had
an advantage there after Bishop B5 which
he probably honestly did but he still
really didn't show anything out of that
position no D6 maybe there's a little
something something and we're getting
the same exact position
here going on but not much at all no
Queen rookie won for the queen of faith
that looked pretty good you might be
thinking about Rook E7 it looks a little
bit awkward but at least you don't hand
over the e-file just yet but no this is
looking fine for Wesley and maybe
maximum has a slight Improvement
somewhere just to keep the tension a
little bit longer just to prevent this
A6 Bishop C6 thing and do you see that
Wesley shook his head I wonder why
yeah did he not like the move Queen f8 I
mean
he's shaking his head at the current
weather in in Minnesota
can't believe you never know you never
know why players shake their heads
that's one lesson I've learned over the
course of my Chester you never know
what's going on inside their heads or if
it's even related to chess well I know
it's going outside your head Queen C3
which you mentioned earlier your idea C5
Queen G3 well he's just playing this
solidly let me ask you does it feel like
Maxime is playing that he doesn't mind a
draw or do you think he actually
believes in the prospects of this
position well we know for a fact that
he's perhaps the most principal GM at
the top like he will not Bend he
continues to play his openings he really
believes in them right he's not trying
to put on a show and say oh look at me
you know I'm playing the same openings
again and again he truly believes in
them and I think we're seeing that here
he's being very stubborn that might
might ultimately backfire but Robert I'm
on the same page I don't think he just
wants to draw especially given that his
lead has shrunk to two I really think he
wants to prove that his opening Choice
uh is worthwhile but he's getting
nothing he's not doing a good job of it
at all he's getting absolutely nothing
like I think he would be the first to
admit himself Wesley playing this like
okay if you're just gonna let me draw
with black I'll keep trying to win with
white and guess what Wesley has won the
last two games he had the white pieces
now I will point one thing out perhaps
the only chance white could aim for and
this could honestly backfire is an
eventual b2b4 with two ideas if you take
on B4 I'm trying to create an outside
passer with A5 if you ignore then I take
on A5 maybe drop the bishop back to D2
and try to go C4 and pick that pawn up
that might be the only target white can
create but it ain't gonna work against
Wesley he'll stick a bishop on B3 and
goodbye it should be three right now
right you played Bishop B5 I can repeat
moves or you can start bringing my king
toward the center F5 King F7 King E6 and
that pawn on A4 if you can protect the
C6 square like if your king were on B7
black already plays C6 and wins him yeah
so I don't think you're able to make
that work just yet but black can start
expanding F5 King F7 King E6 all that
kind of stuff and eventually C7 to C5
you better watch out for that because
you can strike in the center and open up
your Bishop while White's pawns are
stuck in place yeah I mean this pathway
is just wide open it's like the lights
of a Runway lighting up at night
directing the airplane toward D5 and if
anybody has to be careful it is now
squarely mvl Robert a very sloppy move
25th of a bishop D3 just allowing Bishop
B3 was was careless and it was a
frustration move I think MBL is
frustrated that he's not getting
anything and it's getting to him right
now and he's got to keep his composure
because you absolutely can lose an end
game like this against Wesley you can
and what's the next idea C4 for white
you're not going to trap this bishop on
B3 so please play C4 then black plays D5
and all of a sudden you're gonna be left
with an isolated Pawn at minimum and
maybe worse so you can't really play for
a win here if you're Maxime I feel like
you just need to set kind of you know
agree that this position should just be
a draw and well now
wait wait now King D6 and C6 was a
threat your idea and so Maxime feeling
the desperation pushing C4 out of
necessity not out of Desire now if black
stubbornly plays King D6 there might be
a C5 check
and there why it looks okay well then
there's a swap on C5 and then C6 black
anyway live who knows wow this is this
is actually getting a bit dicey and look
at that move by West classic Wesley I I
don't really know why he did that maybe
he wants to be king see through Bishop
B4 check or something like just uh swab
off Bishops maybe he's okay that's the
Wesley show that we all know right if I
can make a draw with black in a neutral
position without worrying he often goes
for that because on the grand scale of
things the strategy is let's just hold
it black and try to press the white is
there a case to be made for C5 here
again not trying to play for a win just
the most clinical way to force a draw if
you're Maxim or is it King C3
I feel like C5 if you swap on C5 and
then play Black is the way King D6 and
C6 and stuff like I don't know I don't
think it's bad but I feel like there
could be some issues F4
yeah weird Pawn play there's also the
immediate C6 by the way we should point
out Bishop C6 DC no clue what's
happening there
he trades on D5 I'm I'm not predicting a
single one of these moves are you like
it's like all of this is weird I'm very
surprised why would you do this you're
just like asking for a worse end game
unless Max team has mapped this out so
this is for sure a draw this feels like
practically speaking a really bad
decision the problem when you map end
games like this out is there's always
some breakthrough you didn't anticipate
and this is a classic rubber there's
always bishopings before it's possible
even here of course white will play
Bishop he won the point is ghg3 and
black remotes upon but it's so easy to
miss this in time pressure when you put
your Bishop on the wrong Square
at Wesley can keep trying here ad
nauseam and you mentioned this idea
earlier for white to play B4 but now
black can try to play B5 at any moment
including now because if you swap twice
on B5 then B3 Falls an outside pass Pawn
the issue is the A5 Pawn is targeted by
the bishop on D2 but that is something
that Wesley would like to look for uh he
goes after the D4 Pawn First and maybe
it was C5 C5 a weird looking it he's
played it he wants to play Bishop D4 and
Bishop to G1 the target is the H2 Pawn
so Maxime hanging by a thready thread
here
and M oh Wesley continues to make
progress but can mvl hold things
together just enough Bishop D4 what's
his idea is it Bishop E3 Bishop E3 in
the point he's tracking before there's
always Bishop E6 so you if you take on
B3 you lose F5
and that is hard to evaluate but
probably not worth it if you're Wesley
so oh Bishop A4 is a threat little
little threat over there and Bishop E6
going right up to the F5 pawn and I
think we're just gonna see a draw now
great play by Wesley he did everything
he could but at the end of the day I
feel holding by a thread and they're
just going to keep an eye on F5 and B3
needs to be safe and sound so white is
less active makes the draw I think
that's a pretty fair result I mean
Maxine he's yet to prove anything in
this line on the white side and now he
goes back to Sicilian so interesting
Donna he's going away from the pet shop
he lost two games in that line even if
the opening wasn't the problem and we're
getting oh my gosh we're getting this a
bishop B5 check I would have expected
the opposite MBO isn't really having
problems with black in the pet shop and
he switches that he is having problems
proving anything in the rookie one
Berlin and yet that he sticks with so
interesting decision making I'm not
going to question it mvl knows better
but kind of interesting to always Trace
how these players decide which openings
to keep and which openings to change and
this Robert is such a classic line it's
been around for uh for for decades it
makes me sad because whenever I've had
this position with black I feel like I
have no plans no space and I just have
to wait and try to play as you're
showing D5 but then when I finally
played D5 it's always the wrong moment
and I lose material so A6 okay is you is
really E5 on the docket doesn't look
like it just yet so you'll play Rook C1
you can make a mistake but a four at
some point for white as well you've got
95 at the right moment but that will
allow B5 so you do it to be a bit
careful for Wesley as he sinks deeper
into thought and sinks deeper uh below
his camera but the problem with black is
threatening Knight takes D4 and then B5
and I say threatening in quotes
obviously it's not like black waves B5
and the game is over but there's a
well-known trick here Robert I missed
this before let me make a random move
for white we can pull up an announcement
real fast Knight T4 Bishop D4 B5 you
automatically take on B5 and suddenly
black has this move E5 and the Knight
defends the queen so you don't have
Bishop takes E5 if you move the bishop
you obviously lose the Knight so lots of
these weird tricks that black has In the
Sicilian in general and so Wesley drops
his Knight away from D4 in the live game
and this does take this thing out of B5
I think Wesley has done a phenomenal job
of rewriting his Knights today I think
that's one specific thing that he has
done where he's either got Knight C to
E2 in the first game here Knight dd2 and
B5 anyway not to be denied what happens
if you just take twice on B5 where is
Black's counter play is there some kind
of Knight B4 going after the A2 Pawn
then why can you play A4 I don't believe
in that maybe it's to give up the pawns
like D5 and strike in the center I like
the spirit of mvl's play but I'm a
little bit skeptical about the reality
so Wesley I think is going to take twice
I think Knight before is the idea and
white just drops the Knight back to C3
and says hey I've got connected
passwords on the queen side that is a
massive asset so you better show
something Concrete in the next couple of
moves but some Thanksgiving Wesley
policy or Robert what could it be and he
doesn't go for it he goes Knight D5 and
that's a bad move yeah I don't like that
engine drops I mean if we just take a
second and
now think about this the C file is open
there's a black work on C8 the white
Rooks are not connected uh Knight B4
played if you move the Rook from A1 you
lose A2 if you keep the Rook there
Bishop takes A1 is a threat and as
you're pointing out Bishop D4 is met by
Knight C2 hey bishop
oh gosh Queen A7 check is another move
you have to keep track of there once the
Bishops are gone
I think Bishop D4 works tactically it's
important to point out Robert I'm not
going to make these moves on the board
but just notice that after the trade on
G7 Knight E3 is met by a check on D4 so
that doesn't quite work
but perhaps black can play Bishop takes
D4 and then Queen A7 or something like
that or Knight C2 as you were saying
Knight suit Bishop G7 King G7 Rook C1
then Queen A7 check oh
oh that's nasty yeah just correcting the
move orders always essential in these
positions so Maxime doing what he does
best getting a lead on the clock and
then spending his time at the right
moment but for Wesley I mean he could
have captured on B5 I don't know what he
was worried about exactly but it's
playing into Maxim's hands I really
don't see what the defense is after
Knight C2 because I guess Queen A7 check
you're gonna have to meet with the
incredibly awkward move Rook F2 so that
Knight E3 is not a fork but that looks
terrifying for black there must be
something else Maxime is attracted to I
think it is Bishop takes D4 and queen A7
because that also gives his Rook Robert
this very nice C3 Square later on in the
game if he can force white to recapture
with the Knight which he does right
because Bishop D4 Queen D4 Knight C2 is
immediately a problem so as you're
pointing out Queen A7 to follow up
threatens Knight C2 with a pin Knight
threads Rook C3 to Rook D3 trying to win
that piece so I actually really like the
look of it and he goes for that
variation Queen A7 is on the board and
Rook F2 here is possible that way you
break the pin uh with your Rook but if
Rook F2 then there's Rook C3 with the
thread of happening Rook C3 is a nasty
little move sinks his teeth into all
sorts of weak squares on the queen side
and tactics Galore here he can just
double on the C file Black's position is
quite easy to play is Knight C2
available here
oh my Lance and he's played it this is
great
lpdo
oh but look at how fortunate uh White is
here Knight D4 Rook D4 you have no way
to actually attack it he plays on beside
you can't win The Rook but look at the
pressure on White's position
and very instructive moment there from
Maxime keeping the tension there's no
93. he's on his Queen he went the wrong
way oh my gosh Wesley man
that is unthinkable King H1 and he's
still in the game yeah that was a very
surprising turn of events Wesley didn't
take on B5 and everything fell apart
right after that now we go back to a
sicilian but this time it's Wesley with
black
yeah it took me a second to I had to
tell myself that like three times no
Maxime is not playing with the black
pieces Maximus playing white and he has
essayed the once Ultra popular h3g4
system which has cooled down in the last
couple of years but man that was that
was crazy and I think mech's team is
pausing because he wonders what Wesley
wants from him uh G4 is an option it
still is an option especially with this
Pawn H6 it can become a hook what's a
hook when you play G4 and G5 you open up
the G file because the pawn on H6 is
under attack however black hasn't Castle
kingside so maybe G4 uh while you have
the potential of opening up things it's
not super scary for black to meet oh and
mvl turning this positional the way this
line was taught to me white generally
plays Queen F3 and then castles Queen
said that's another reason you play H3
to prevent Bishop G4 which would pin the
queen to The Rook on D1 but mvl actually
saying no I actually want to Castle
Queen side here as far as I can tell and
maybe stick a knight on D5 but that does
look a little bit artificial Robert I
don't know about this and this Pawn E6
is actually a really useful Pawn you
take away the D5 Square permanently
which allows the Knight and F6 to move
out the way if you want
um you can now play Knight C6 without
any issue uh you can Castle kingside
have a semi-open f file and he plays B5
so Wesley he's expanding on the queen
side I don't know if that was explicitly
necessary just because B4 isn't I mean
it is a threat because E4 might drop but
at the same time you sort of extend your
queen side allows white to put A4 at the
right moment as well yeah I've lost a
lot of games in the night off because
I've put the pawn on B4 and then a loud
white to open up the queen side with A3
you mentioned the hook on H6 the pawn on
B4 would also serve as a hook but more
of a positional hook obviously because
your king is on the other side but a
hook nonetheless as white piles up on
the D6 spawn but as it stands it's very
well defended by that Bishop on E7 yes
and by hook or by crook this will be the
last game before we get a break because
is looking at the match look we're about
halfway through the three plus one type
control so for Wesley I do think he
needs to settle down a bit right he lost
that game in surprising fashion uh to go
down three once more and now he's
playing the Sicilian so I feel like he's
in a kind of twist of events that you
don't typically see from him he's
playing on emotion his position in this
game is quite nice so it's actually
working out for him but I do believe he
changed the Sicilian because he feels
like he has to win and when you play for
results that usually backfires though
right now Donna this is all you could
ever ask for for black
yeah and there's a good Russian
Expressions to change the record player
which basically means to change the the
course of the game right to change the
nature of the position just make a big
change give yourself a fresh set of
positions to deal with and I like that
decision from Wesley he didn't play E4
H5 right he's not tilted the night off
is a pretty reputable line and Wesley
has played it a lot in the past so I'm
fully approving of this decision and I
think that the position speaks for
itself if he goes D5 here he's got all
that he can eat with the black pieces
well he hasn't moved yet so D5 is
available to him
um he's still thinking about the
position what other move candidates come
on Knight B6 is typical trying to get
the Knight to C or A4 yeah if the bishop
takes on B6 at least you have uh the
dark squares under your control the F2
pawns a bit tender
um so he goes Rook B8 what now that I
really dislike the just the look of that
I mean is he is A5 really worth
disrupting your coordination over Robert
that was surprising I that was not a
move that I had in mind and Knight G3
apparently not the best either so Here
Comes The Rook F to C8 say let's go the
king side is not vulnerable the E6 Pawn
Dunya it covered D5 earlier now covers
that five now Knight D2 I Like It
prepares C2 C4 Now using the B5 Pawn as
a hook in comes Wesley's night but maybe
that's why MBL put the Knight on G3 so
that here he could drop the queen back
to E2 but watch out for Knight A4 that's
actually a super nasty move because if
you force Rook B1 then you drop C2 and
this you pointed out is a big concession
from White yes give me those dark
squares but look at that move and
forcing the king in and Knight F5 is
possible the bishop slides back to f8
very likely and what'd you really get
out of this you got a nice little tactic
it's a pin good for you you're not
winning anything so I think Bishop f8
does the trick and Knight to E3 he wants
some kind of C4 but C4 can be met by B4
and very importantly done it right now
the queen on C5 can't be kicked out
that's nope actually really an
instructive thing you would love to kick
that Queen out play C4 something like
that but the queen is sitting very
pretty on C5 and it won't let me play an
ip3 another chess.com glitch
and Knight G4 played instead so do you
want to trade Knights what do you think
is Wesley
um to H5 I'm tempted by Knight h5904 I
guess Knight H5 oh G3 Knight takes G3
again that Queen on C5
doing work he goes Knight H7 so a kind
of Rue lopez-like idea to bring the
Knight to G5 and the dark Squad Bishop
can travel to H6 interesting King side
play by Wesley so I don't know who it
who it's gonna favor this is getting
spicy but uh the time control I mean the
time situation right now oh maximum a
little bit ahead three I love Bishop H6
Rook D3 looks pretty good to me the
Knight come back to F6 hitting the E4
Pawn how you can defend the pawn E4 well
there's our answer I think that's why he
goes Ricky one he wants the Rook to make
contact the four Pawn but it's not
making contact because of this pesky
Knight on E3 which you can't move
because the other Rook is pinned so
Queen C6 here would really press on that
pawn B4 is in the mix as well but I
think for the time being Robert mvl is
holding everything together I really
like the idea B4 for black I mean it
just causes quite a ton of problems and
you can't take with the c-pawn you lose
a piece so B4 looks good typical Wesley
just King G7 and Rook f8 switching once
again to the king side I like it I
actually think it's better because
people without Knight to C4 now the
knights are moving backwards they're
Superfluous pieces fighting for the same
squares Rook F7 rook f8 in terms of a
bullet game at this point great for
black but the time is better for one
time and I pointed out before the three
minute segment started mvl I think has
been getting the upper hand in these
time scrambles so let's see if Wesley
can turn the trend around and keep his
composure Knights are super super
dangerous pieces when you've got 10
seconds on your clock great and White's
got more of them than black yeah but
great move B4 to cement the B5 Pawn in
place if you take C3 lose B5 Queen C4
great move by Wesley let's trade the
knights aren't getting in the bishop on
HX covers and here comes the second Rook
Rook fc7 on the docket the C3 Pawn is
now weaker than B5 which is basically
inaccessible you might need to play
Knight B1 here to defend the C3 pawn and
I think he will wow a really ugly here
comes the king to E7 and typical
Sicilian endgame fashion oh okay five
rugby seven everything defended oh wow
Robert E3 I think Wesley should have put
a rook on the a file while he had a
chance he's given mvl a lot of activity
on the queen side but here we go the
Rooks are traded now Knight C7 back
followed by Rook A7 again herfluous
Knights Bishop C1 Rook A7 let's open
things up let's take advantage of
White's misplaced pieces and mvl he had
an opportunity to play C4 and activate
his Knights he doesn't do it a
repetition are we gonna get a repetition
no we're not okay I think yes we are
what's he doing Wesley you could play
for a win Rook A7
I don't think he's doing it four seconds
on the clock he doesn't want to risk it
I don't know he doesn't really risk it
after Rook A7 you called it well you
gotta risk it to get the biscuit and
right now it's a three-point deficit for
Wesley so I mean he's going to regret I
believe that moment there uh maybe for
now he's just like all right I'll get a
white piece of the next game he is a
very pragmatic individual he's won the
global Championship right that's a rapid
time control he's had the highest highs
that you could imagine winning the
official random World Championship in
2019 but right now done it it just feels
like in these critical moments Maxine
vashilagrav is just a little bit more
crisp he is and listen there isn't that
much time left in the match there's like
50 minutes on the overall match clock
and the way this match is gone they've
gone back and forth neither side has
been able to build up all that much
momentum definitely not Wesley so so at
this point you really have to exploit
your opportunities and you have to turn
up the risk dial if you're Wesley so
which I know isn't necessarily his style
but let's see how he manages to adjust
his strategy on the other side of this
three plus one segment yeah what you're
saying holds true I think Wesley with
the lead is as scary as it gets Wesley
with the deficit not really the
stylistic uh type of player who will
take those risks but he needs to he did
play Sicilian he actually played quite
nicely but in those critical moments
sometimes you just have to say I'm all
in and Wesley so he's often a bit more
restrained he's a fantastic player who's
having a pretty decent match if you just
get a few more things right maybe he
will be able to mount this combat but
we'll see after this break we'll return
for more from three plus one time Patrol
and it's Maxine from Schiller grab
Wesley so quarterfinal speed chess
championship match
what is this this is duck chess you guys
this is a new variant it's called duck
chess chest but with a duck quack quack
how to play duck chest the duck is a
brick pieces cannot move through the
square occupied by the duck okay kind of
square to place the dog
[Music]
oh he put the deck to prevent moves of
opponent not yourself
Yeah so basically you do this and this
cannot move I'm gonna go Knight F6 and
I'm gonna put the duck in the most
inconvenient place for my opponent to
move no Bishop no Queen so no londons
can permanently stop the London capture
the pawns King to win oh wow oh there's
no stalemate but still wait there is
still me but the still made the player
wins oh if only that was real chess I
think I'm getting the hang of this game
I think I think I actually am getting
the hang of it
I think this works oh that's a horrible
blunder oh my God I just blundered I
have to move something else first then
doc and Knight will take my king this is
the best way to lose the dark chess
[Music]
there are some real bullet skills right
there boys this is the first time
winning duck chest
so exciting
oh no no no no no no slip no no no no no
no
a duck chess champion give me those
points baby
[Music]
foreign
as we return we look at the blitz
insights on chess.com between these two
players Donya both depleted
approximately the same amount of games
they both are extremely accurate but
look at that win percentage for maxim
that's pretty crazy
it is and my eyes are also drawn to the
low number at the bottom losses by flag
neither one of them really have a lot of
problems with time management but mvl is
a lot faster than people realize back in
the days of the internet chess club mvl
had one of the highest bullet ratings on
the site something nobody seems to
realize the guy is a bullet monster his
time management in Blitz is excellent
and you don't win as many Blitz Games as
he does by accident MPL has been firing
on all cylinders thus far he certainly
has and as you you were noting he does
not lose on time very often you know if
it doesn't we don't time very often but
either way he has a three-point lead in
this match Wesley so one of the most
accurate players on the site 89 average
accuracy that's crazy but he also
doesn't take risks that's what we were
talking about before the break Tanya and
if he is going to beat Maxine
vashilagrav not only does he need to
make the most of his advantages he
probably will have to take some risk
that that may be speculative listen it's
a good board game not as good as Katan
but it's also what he needs to take a
lot more of especially in the second
half of this three plus one segment I
mentioned in the pre-show Robert that a
three-point deficit going into the
bullet has been far from insurmountable
for most players in the SEC thus far
we've seen at least two comebacks on
improbable comebacks in the Bullet by
players we don't really think of as
traditional bullet players but just the
way this match has gone as the next game
kicks off it doesn't seem all that
probable that either player is going to
be able to put together a super long
streak so Wesley has to start chipping
away at this lead in these 25 minutes
yes he does and we have a gruntfeld one
of the openings that I named earlier as
a vintage mvl opening and Knight E4 this
line has been played many times I played
it from the white side I actually really
like it uh from the white side because
you don't get into your standard Theory
Donya you waste the tempo in a way
playing Bishop G5 then right back to F4
but with the 10 tension between the C4
and D5 pawns it remains and there's not
a knight on F6 at the moment Knight
takes D5 is often by Queen A5 check it
gets spicy that's precisely what I was
gonna say it may seem if you're not a
grinfeld player that both sides are just
experiencing a blind spot with respect
to the D5 Pawn but it is standard fare
to sacrifice at times both of your DNC
Pawns in the grunfeld because it's all
about piece activity
and look at this bishop E5 it's a
topical move just trying to shut down
the bishop on G7 and it's a really weird
position where black can take on C3 and
take back on D5 and white seems to be
well behind in development but you also
better control the center let's count
the pause of the center e and D for
white only e for black so this should be
at least a slight something for Wesley
heading into the end game oh definitely
a smidge here with that uh increased
control over the a file a lot of uh Pawn
Mobility a very flexly Pawn formation on
the queen side
and uh I hope James approved of that I
hope he's watching the show oh he for
sure is and well right now we see King
D2 it's an end game we can use our King
as a weapon we don't have to hide it on
the side of the board Rook d8 trying to
play E5 there is a king in the center so
we can open up this line then the king
suffers and Bishop D3 so what happens if
we just swing 25 E5
great minds think alike I think MBL is
on the cusp of erasing whatever small
Advantage Wesley may have had you can
also take and go Knight C5 to E4 but I
like that less there's E5 and
importantly if you go D5 Robert not only
is there a knight C5 trick there's also
E4 and Knight C5 and White's position
starts to collapse there and look as
with Rook E1 by Wesley if you take on D4
in comes my knight and remember that
game where you were saying the bishop
didn't have like a stronghold right
there was an anchored Square this Knight
on D4 is anchored there by the pawn C3
the King on D3 may have been exposed and
some of the other variations but it can
always slide back to C2 and look at this
as well A1 to D1 The Rook on A1 has done
its job it induced the move A6 now it's
free to go not saying that there's much
of an advantage for white but all of
Wesley's moves are with purpose yeah I
stand corrected I thought MBL solved all
of his problems he still has a couple
left to solve and maybe he can start by
playing King to F6 that seems to be a
pretty safe square and you're also
preventing The Rook infiltration E7 he
plays a more modest King f8 maybe he was
worried uh that the King on F6 would get
harassed by the Rooks it looks visually
like a dead equal position but if you
look closely you'll see that White's
pieces are just a tad more active but
hey active pieces don't win games can
Wesley convert this into something
concrete Robert what do you think one
important thing to look out for is if
that rook and did slides to E8 like
right now Knight E6 check is available
just trying to ruin the black pawn
structure it's a trade of Knight it's
just a little bit fancy but it gives
white a little bit of an edge so Knight
F6 played first Rook E8 to follow I
don't see how white infiltrates but look
at this move C4 King C3 King B4 King A5
King B6 I know it's a long seven King B8
King B9 if Nigel short made it work in
his game against yon tiemann the king
going to its dream Square you have to
look for things like that and if you
play King C3 now though there is this
Knight check on D5 no pass around go
back to B2 but it's definitely really a
valid idea in the long run maybe get
this night off of D4 open a line of
communications between the Rooks I I
still think we're talking about a a
symbolic Advantage at Best But if I had
to choose one side I would still choose
white with this Knight re-maneuvering
itself perhaps to E3
C3 but I'm starting like this more and
more for white because as long as you
keep one pair of Rooks on the board I
feel like you have this uh sort of clear
path on the queen side whereas what's
Black's actual plan right now well what
if you play rookie 7 and force the Rooks
off the board ah because I go Rook D1
you have Knight E4 checks very important
but I agree with you I still think in
the night end game White's King is
slightly more active whitesnite a little
bit more jumpy and Wesley at the very
least could pretend to try speaking of
active Kings he says I'm just gonna go
that away and that was smart play by
Maxime F3 if we trade Rooks my king gets
a D4 my knight gets to D3 it's not just
the clearest cut draw that we've ever
seen no no even if it should be a draw a
great example of not trusting the eval
bar too much now it is showing a small
Advantage for white which is accurate
objectively but practically this is even
more unpleasant you want to play a
well-timed C5 check but you don't want
to do it too early and you definitely
don't want to combine it with a trade of
knights because then black is the one
who's going gonna have an outside pass
spawn so Pawn endings are actually good
for black here because of the
availability of this A5 Pawn brake
and you could chop on A5 playing Knight
A4 but like a king C6 and Knight B6 I I
I'm with you but suddenly it's like
black who's on the better side of the
Drone it's time to look at your opponent
and say all right let's call it a day
now let's call it a day before it gets
bad maybe King C3 is what the doctor
ordered all of a sudden you're
absolutely right it might be black in
the driver's seat before you know it
C5 check was possible as well
but Wesley playing cautiously this is
going to be a draw
yeah King C6 is always a nice location
for that piece and you can't really do
much of anything right there's no
especially declined to draw
wow I wonder if he didn't see it because
sometimes you have the board full screen
and you don't see
but it reminds me of something
you can tell me what it is or well I was
playing the the Riga uh open in 2014 I
offered Mackenzie mulner very strong GM
lives in New Jersey and a good friend I
offered him a draw it was a complicated
middle game so he thought for about 10
minutes and then he looks at me and he
says what
and he's like did you say something and
I'm like yeah Mac I asked you how your
day went like I offered a draw and he
said all right all right I'll take it
yeah he only heard it well after it was
said he's just saying let's trade
Knights and if you trade nice BC is
check with the F4 Pawn being loose you
have to calculate this and Wesley hey 10
seconds fake it no he takes the pawn why
would a move oh my God but now it's
getting sharp oh he smokes if 95 going
on gh6 and you've been outside passed
spawn but that's a three result game
maybe just take G5 given that you have a
three-point lead maybe play this
conservatively just take the Jeep on and
take your draw and go yeah that seems to
be a very smart play just take on G5
with either Pawn in fact and then we
have an even King end game that's what
Max team does and this position is dead
yeah okay draw just making sure and a
great decision by MBL practical prudent
chassis you're up by three no need to
ReDiscover the wheel just take the darn
draw yeah some people may criticize
Maxine for not playing it out a little
more wasting some of the match clock
we've seen some people do that's a great
effect but we're still too early right
what's the point of playing that out you
have a three-game lead
um it just I think sets the wrong tone
for the rest of the match for yourself
yeah I think starting to get really
concerning now for flexley I'm looking
at the match clock it's at 18 minutes
the lead is not shrinking mvl's got the
white pieces so time for Wesley to
really turn it on here if he wants a
crack at this lead okay we have a
rosalimo and a traditional rosalimo now
what's interesting Robert is that
players used to go H3 here automatically
and in the last few years people kind of
realize that the idea of black trading
the light script Bishop isn't always
something to fear Wesley could still go
H3 and he does but our understanding of
this rosalima line has really changed
Through The Years what's funny is you
said Wesley can play H3 but it's Maxine
I apologize the reason why you did that
is Maxine was the one playing the
wrestling earlier like yeah exactly they
did the nighter of Switcheroo and now
russellimo switch row it's very
surprising what's happening in this
magic I think that's been good for
Maxine's perspective is Wesley who is
someone who likes to be in control of
the chessboard and Maxime is just
switching his openings up left and right
he has a lead it's making Wesley get
outside his comfort zones but look at
this position it's pretty locked up he
took on C7 just as I was saying in a
locked up position Knights can actually
be superior to Bishops so there goes
that second white Bishop the Knight can
go into E4 now the pawn has been pushed
to E5 oftentimes you see the White Queen
go up to D2 and F4 but that's why Wesley
decided to strike with F5
the pawns look ugly but the next one can
come to F5 and Bishop lg7 will look
pretty strong and where are the outposts
for the white Knights as you're saying
you make that sound but the pawns ain't
actually that bad especially if they
appear on F5 and G5 I love the move d4 I
think mvl has to take it to Wesley
before he completes his development but
Rook d8 is a super alert response just
saying hey the D4 Pawn is now a
liability maybe you should try Queen d
E3 and get it to C4 get out of the pin
but Queen T3 yeah you don't want to go
Bishop F5 if you're if you're black
because this does fork the pawn maybe
take on D4 first it's a chaotic position
though Robert anybody's game thus far
for sure I don't think of King H7 as
well just to keep the tension between
Pawns in the center and take on D4 when
you're good and ready or the G6 Pawn is
loose so that King H7 is a multi-purpose
move he can say it goes Queen F7 once
again a good multi-person taking away
Queen C4 protecting opponent G6 bringing
the queen closer to the king side and
queen E3 is Maxine's response Donya that
move allows the queen eventually to
venture up to E7 but for now gets out of
the pin and black can take and play F6
F5 reopening the fiancado bishop at
which point 96 would run into rookie
eight exploiting that queen as a
vulnerability instead he chips away from
the other side what a committal move I
think that's what's on your mind as well
he's giving up a lot of squares but
everything's defended for the time being
and he's gonna play B6 and maybe bishop
B7 so so he might just take over the
long diagonal and I should say diagonals
because this is the problem with giving
up not just two Bishops versus knight
and Bishop you know it's two Bishops
versus two knights which means your
Knights cannot fend off diagonals your
Knights need to find outposts need to
find attack of some sort so where is
this Knight on D4 going maybe Knight E2
to F4 or something like that I could see
an argument for it and he does play 92
step one and I think Knight F4 to take
it to the E6 Square yeah the knights are
land animals they can run they can climb
but they can't fly and the Bishops can
just fly over obstacles and land from
one side of the board to the other while
the knights have to have to climb that
wall in cumbersome fashion when there
are no strongholds the knights really
really struggle so Maxine doing what he
can here using his Knights to the
maximum and trying to jump into E6 but
these do seem to just be one move
threats which Wesley is handily pairing
thus far and Here Comes The Rook wow
Rook D2 giving up the bishop on G7 which
isn't that good of a piece right now the
pawn F6 keeps it stuck it's not open
that's when the bishop takes live but
the E7 square is a bit of a
vulnerability Rook C2 might even have a
queen D6 something absolutely that could
be scary and then the queen could
further infiltrate to C7 in the event
the black screen moves away from the
seventh Rank and if your Maxime takes in
rookie two the amazing thing uh Robert
is that black can take on A2 at the end
of the line and then return to F7 to
Parry a check on C7 and that's why
Maxine blunts the queen on F7 a very
alert move and I think mvl is holding
this one together a great vision by both
you and then mvl realize the A2 was
actually under attack that would have
been hanging so he plays B3 uh you do
not want to trade off all the Rooks if
you are Wesley because that's how you
get in trouble if the Rooks and the
Queens come off the board some of these
end games can be very dangerous for
black the Knight hops from color complex
the color complex the bishop inherently
limited to its own color so Bishop C6
once again a useful move covers D7
covers B5 the Knight is actually
restricted by the bishop on C6 and H4 a
little poke and prod kind of move trying
to induce more weaknesses on the king
side MBL is happy with the status quo on
his side of the board I mean that Rook
on d8 is undefended you can move it to a
defended Square you can play Rook d8 to
D7 and maybe that's what Wesley does he
does play a move like that and that
essentially forces Maxim's hand I think
it's a big moment because that's a
rookie to Rook to do C2 is loose you do
not want to give up that pawn your queen
isn't getting into the D6 Square to go
rookie seven you're saying rookie two
and after a swap there's Queen D5 black
starts getting active here Queen D1 is a
big well it's actually not really a
threat because white is Queen C7 at the
end but you could lose a pawn there but
that's something really important to
know the queen see some check is always
available to White now don't play Queen
D3 and blunder check me into one yeah
would be a problem he just goes Knight
C3
okay so Queen D7 preventing preventing
White's Queen from infiltrating so
Wesley gonna kind of tread water here
for a bit and try to make some
improvements to his position
and here comes the queen back to F5 it
goes so Queen D3 trades the queens of
the spot but you put a Pawn on a light
square and isolated and the black king
would venture in Via F5 so Queen E5
there's no point that white has to worry
about just yet I feel like there's no
Square that's vulnerable
and look at the clock situation when
you're in acute time pressure you want
to avoid having targets and weaknesses
because they increase the possibility of
a blunder so if you're Wesley you're
considering playing G4 but a big
transformation there is the Queens get
swapped is this just a dead draw or is
black actually playing for a win here I
think black should be the size slightly
for Choice it was B4 locking upon's on a
light Square
is there a C4 move that doesn't look too
threatening oh Bishop G6 uh oh
the Knight meeting the bishop oh my God
but the pawn ending is waiting for black
just taken 25 taking an A5 it's over
maybe even A6 just so you can save a
Tempo but he plays A5 I don't think it
matters oh what a blunder by Maxime that
is borderline inexcusable right like
he's way too strong to allow a simply
winning King opponent game that is basic
Betty right there and after Knight D3
check that pawn end game Robert I think
was
comfortably a draw despite black being
more active wow that was a gift that was
a gift and Wesley so better make the
most of it because now he is the white
side of Sicilian and it's Maxime who's
probably very frustrated you know he's
still in the lead but it's easy to
forget that in the moment when you just
lost the game you're flusterity but it's
H5 we're gonna get a sharp game here
Donna we're gonna get a sharp game we're
gonna get two more games most likely in
the three-minute segment and these two
games actually might decide the match if
Maxine wins both of them he brings this
up to a four point lead that's the ideal
scenario for him if Wesley wins both of
them the match is tied so literally this
could go two completely different ways
let's see how both players adapt to
these very crucial circumstances H3 by
Wesley as he invites the move H4
so there's a funny story about this
position from the Olympiad
um you know after the US team was
struggling uh you know Adam really had a
metal contention there was one day where
all the players were just talking about
this variation like he's having a good
time just getting back to the roots the
enjoyment of Chess and they talked
during this position for like an hour
and a half and I'm talking Wesley Fabi
Lavon Sam Shanklin lenio Dominguez oh
we're just looking at this and I had the
joy of hearing them and trying to
participate as best I could and look at
this move G4 opposant was available but
not played uh because then The Rook
would have gone to the G file and tried
to exploit the open file and this idea
mvl just carried out takes a 95 it's as
old as the hills that Knight on E5 is a
monster and if you remove it from the
board well guess what you're giving away
a very important attacking asset and
you're opening up the D file and both of
those things generally favor Black so
MBL from a broad perspective Robert he
likes these types of positions he's
played them since he was a little child
uh also known as a grand master and
still this could get real spicy if white
sticks and I don't have five for example
it's anybody's game for sure I mean
Knight F5 already looks pretty
interesting you have to watch out for
Knight takes F4 dragging the queen away
from the C2 Square because Knight F4
followed by some kind of Knight takes D3
at the right moment could be detrimental
for white but uh for now there's so many
tactics in the air uh Knight on D4 is
doing such a great job of defending the
F3 Square from a fork eyeing the F5
square jumping there protecting C2 all
at once and to just complete what I just
said I wasn't exaggerating in 2005 when
I played my first world youth Chess
Championship uh it was under 10 years
old in Belfort France mvl was playing
under 18 and he was already a grand
master I mean my parents still had no
Kia phones and fbl I mean I name
whatever crazy object I mean the front
page of CNN.com looked like something
from the Stone Age and mvl was already a
grand master was already playing the
night ORF yeah the night Earth has been
his bread and butter uh you know his
entire life pretty much and Bishop E4
now Knight C3 check looks a bit scary
because after bcbc the B file opens the
king ob1 is in a difficult place but the
Knight on D4 will be able to drop back
and cover the B file so you're
mentioning Knight C4 Knight C3 both of
these ideas are in the air
I would play actually a liquidational
combination if we pull up an announce
well actually no let's not because he's
doing it I was gonna say Knight takes F4
and then after Queen takes up for you
can push the Deep on up to D5 Robert
forcing the queen trade now yes you give
away your extra Pawn but I feel like
that end game is pretty comfortable for
black and MBL might be going for just
that
good call by you uh Queen C7 rickerson
Bishop takes D5 we get a swap of pieces
there and when Coast clears it's even
material and he goes Knight B6 first I
don't love that move but okay I don't
love it either I think retreating wasn't
the way to go Bishop B3 looks very
sensible just I the F7 Pawn
and I think MBL is is looking and
salivating at Wesley's clock he's trying
to play a little bit faster here
but it might be equal according to the
eval bar but suddenly I'm getting real
uncomfortable here given the abundance
of weaknesses that Wesley has to attack
and look at the coordination of White's
pieces all of them nicely clustered in
the center the Knight ready to jump into
F5 mvl is the one who has to tread
cautiously here Robert he's walking on
hot coals and 96 here looks real scary
96 is brilliant Effie rookie six the
King on G in line with the bishop on B3
the Knight on B6 is loose so I think
that wins the piece back so you net a
pawn for white and then all the other
pawns are also in some dangers so 96 a
big opportunity for Wesley so who drops
under 30 seconds Donya yeah management
has not been superb but he finds the
Tactical shot but the good news for
black two pieces of a good news the
first is that you have opposite colored
Bishops the second is that the Rook
infiltrates F3 and that's a result of
the f-file opening so black has a lot of
activity in return for the pawn he's
definitely worse here or maybe not even
worse as he activates his rook and tries
to put it on E5 and Rook takes H3 is
going to be a threat there's one big
problem for what you need this bishop on
D3 but Bishop C4 Rook takes H3 is
available he plays A4 to get Luft for
the king but he's going so fast his
Bishop needs to be on D3 I really feel
strongly about that just putting
pressure on G6 and he can put it on D3
He Can Play Bishop C4 but instead he
goes for The Rook trade okay and you can
trade Rooks like rookie one check and
that's very likely a draw but for Maxine
why would you ever do that
and Maxime if you're Maxime you kind of
want to milk the clock I think you want
the next game to be the last who's the
one pressing here white is still up upon
that pawn ain't going anywhere
especially now as it's blockaded I think
that the worst is behind Wesley but can
mvl create complications in his time
pressure what do you think Rook A3
Bishop C3 throwing Checkmate something
like that from yeah something like that
maybe King G5 you know pretend that
you're paying for something in a dream
no no no and Wesley so he is the player
who has the most draws by agreement uh
on chess.com and he makes a job right
there I think it looked like with proper
play we could have seen him drop a
proper play proper being the key word
we're playing speed chess we're into the
bullet scrambles at that point just play
it out come on
at least milk a minute off the clock
before accepting the draw because you
want to go into the bullet with a
guaranteed lead you don't want to give
Wesley more chances especially since I
would argue the momentum right now is
kind of on Wesley's side the match is
sort of up for grabs here but I guess
MBL says hey I have the white pieces
I've been doing well with the white
pieces let's not extend that game any
further and we have yet another rosalimo
with mvl on the white side well spoiler
alert for those who are not watching
France has the lead in their World Cup
match maybe uh for Max seems like yeah
that's enough the country can do it I
don't need to extend mine but here this
game is very important it may very well
be the last of this type Patrol as your
four minutes of 45 seconds in that and
you see the times for the players it
adds up to more but right now Dania this
is a big moment for Wesley he is the
bishop pair he has played this position
before you see the D4 Square under
control if white plays D4 that gives
white some space for pieces but un
doubles Black's Pawn so it's give and
take
it is give and take and H3 is the
traditional move in such positions to
limit the mobility and activity of the
light squared bishop and this speaking
of typical Robert this structure is so
important to fully understand if you
want to play the rosalimo with either
color black wants to play in many cases
King's Indian style F7 F5 but you
actually sometimes see white trying to
carry out the equivalent Pawn break not
in this case though as mvl goes
defensive with Rook to E1 he does and F5
is a possibility we need to look at the
E5 Pawn it's like Queen E6 and that
white often plays A4 Knight D2 Knight C4
things like that
um that's in the air but what does it
really thread right step one black often
plays A5 and this bishop on C8 that's
the big question mark Donya does it go
to E6 does it sit on C8 and you play F5
it's not always easy to determine where
it should go but you pointed out
something very important and this is not
just a logistical inconvenience it's a
problem you can never really play a five
as long as the Knight is on H5 because
the g-pawn is overextended and you can't
take back with the pawn which of course
is the only reason and you would play F5
otherwise you're just handing white a
big Square in the center for his Knight
right you never want to take a piece on
F5 that's true so right now F5 is off
the table so Knight F4 plates on the
table again look at the queen on C7 it's
doing everything it's protecting B6 it's
protecting the Knight on F4 and really
the pawn that will land on F4 if you
take and you don't really want to take
on F4 because the bishop on G7 becomes
an absolute monster
it most certainly does and dilemma time
for Maxime who drops his Knight back to
E2 trying to trade on his own terms and
keep this bishop under lock and key but
taking an F5 is now
the most on the table that F5 has been
all game
if you take on C4 again Knight E6
happening and then F5 just let's keep
peace on the board I firm control the D4
Square I would love to hop my knight in
there and with the queen on F3 and I
work on f8 F5 would be on the table but
look at this Maxime is thinking here he
takes the C4 and pre-move
let's go and c2c3 is is often automatic
but mvl says hey my priority is to stop
at five because that move causes a lot
of havoc on the king side but Robert
don't you get the sense that Wesley's
just feeling more confident right now
he's playing faster he's playing more
with more energy and right now the match
is kind of teetering in the balance on
the result of this game yes and C3
protects the D4 square and doesn't allow
the knight in but it gives the D3 square
up so Rook D3 rook d8 and so on it said
Rook D6 I like that by Wesley and the
reason why I like it it's already in a
more protected square if you go Rook
takes D6 now you won't take back with
the Rook you'll take back with the queen
and control the game's only open file so
Wesley instead of going the full
distance with the Rook he stops on D6 I
like that Knight back to F1 H5 by Wesley
I love the way he's playing this game
his small incremental progress I'm
irrationally concerned about a draw for
though I'm thinking about building an
alkyne's gun and saying give me that D
file that's exactly what Wesley says he
has this configuration Maxime can play
Rook D2 if he wants to be koi but it's
not like giving up the D file ends the
game I mean you can take on D6 drop your
queen back to E2 to prevent the queen
infiltration to D3 and say how are you
going to make progress but Maxim
he doesn't want to give it away without
some concessions but Queen D3 coming
next yeah so he shares the trade Queen
D3 is possible here as you're mentioning
at some point King H7 following Bishop
H6 as well there's King H7 step one you
are on a roll I'm just letting you
commentate well the problem now is Queen
D3 doesn't work because Queen F7 the
pawn is hanging so uh you know playing
Queen D3 first as you were suggesting
might have been a little more precise
yeah and I was I meant it more in
response to Knight takes D2 Bishop takes
D2 just looked awkward to me but it
makes sense that preventing Queen D3 or
at least taking the sting out of it is
the top priority for white Wesley taking
a healthy think here maybe trying to
figure out a way to get a five in but
Robert again there isn't a piece on H5
anymore now there's a Pawn on H5 but
it's the same problem where you can
never abandon it so Wesley has to think
exclusively in the center
yes and where is he gonna go after
Bishop of Fate where's the bishop going
can't go to E7 uh maybe the King was led
over to G7 but then it begs the question
why did he play King H7 to begin with
and after Queen E2 F5 still not
available the H5 Pawn is loose as is the
E5 Pawn I'm wondering if it's Queen D3
time last game of the segment it is
official as the ticker gets down to zero
and the players continue to maneuver the
structure is virtually symmetrical but
black holds the keys to the kingdom here
let's see if Wesley can continue
squeezing and F5 would be a necessary
move to try to play for a win but not
easy to do that's why I play Queen E8
but allowing The Rook trade so alert by
uh and maximum offering a draw and
Wesley accepting it and again Robert
just it's not that taking a draw here
doesn't make sense at this point it is a
dead draw but maybe keeping the heavy
pieces on the board and just trying to
pound at it a little bit more would have
served Wesley better
yes I mean Wesley he's out of this chair
but still very much in this match it is
a two-point difference between these two
players and you see on the scoreboard
and I think by play Wesley did win that
time segment I think that was actually
quite clear
yeah he did and it may seem like Maxime
has been ahead all match long and other
than the first game it's been basically
wire to wire put a two-point lead I said
it's nothing uh going to three minute
segment Robert I I stick by my words I
mean what is two bullet wins in a row
this lead is incredibly tenuous and mvl
will have to continue bringing his
A-game if he wants to keep his
incredibly strong opponent at Bay he
absolutely must and as you said you know
wire to wire lead for Maxime unless he
lose it in the bullet but something that
is wired to wired is chess is played
year round and the chest does not stop
just because the New Year's around the
corner in fact the 2023 daily Chess
Championship is starting January 1st 5
000 in cash prizes are up for grabs this
year so don't miss your chance to enter
this tournament and prove your daily
chess prowess drop the command daily
Champs in the chat for more info on the
tournament and in the meantime while you
do that and sign yourself up for the
daily championship Donya and I will be
right back and return it's bullet time
here at the quarter finals of speeches
championship this match between Wesley
so and Maxime vestir lagrove
[Music]
just played an exciting game and want to
see if you got a brilliancy or maybe
where you could have improved
chess.com's game review is just a click
away game review is a fast fun and
instructive guided review of your games
see your accuracy and your opponent's
accuracy check out the eval graph for an
instant overview and scroll down to see
how many great moves best moves blunders
and yes brilliancies you have played
learn from chess.com's coach who gives
move explanations opening statistics and
shows you the best lines of play
with retry mistakes you can get another
shot at finding missed opportunities
try game review today on web iOS or
Android
foreign
[Music]
within the Tempest the best have come to
test their skills and brave the storm
oh
my goodness the wheels the wheels have
come out that could be the magic for
some this is familiar ground oh my
goodness Knight d8 whoa
oh my God what a tactic
this is insane oh look at Fabby
exhausting every last resource the
battles will be electric
the moves will be fast it's game over
it's winning oh my God yes it is he's
gonna make a queen the stakes will be
high he just grabs his head he can't
believe it he just gave away the pawn
the 2022 speed Chess Championship is now
fasten your speed belts my friends we're
in for a wild ride
we enter the bullet portion of this SEC
match between Mexico
with a two-point lead for the Frenchman
with three names Dania we had some
excitement in both the five plus one
where Maxime dominated and then the
three plus one where Wesley bounced back
but now heading into the bullet a
two-point lead for Maxime how does
wessie fulfill the comeback
well it's been a back and forth match
both players have brought their a game
but ultimately mvl has played the better
chess I think for Wesley the importance
of taking risks Robert is higher than
ever you just cannot afford to play
conservatively a two-point lead it's not
big it can be erased in the span of two
or three minutes but Wesley has to get
sharp positions out of the opening and
most importantly he's got to be
tactically alert I mean mvl can afford a
blunder here and there Wesley cannot
because if this lead balloons to four if
MBL wins the first two games of the
bullet I think this match is going to
get away from Wesley I'm with you and
smart chess was with Maxine versus
before the match started smart Choice's
predictions had Maxime winning this time
control six to four now he also had a
tie in five plus one and Maxine instead
of Wesley winning three plus one but if
his predictions are ever to be believed
that Maxime with the two-point lead and
being the favorite in bullet that would
be bad news for Wesley sober
Daniel Wesley is a global Champion you
know he withstood some serious tests in
that rapid time control he's only lost
to a current Magnus in the SEC so if
anyone could put up a fight be resilient
and bounce back it's Wesley so
I feel confident that I can definitely
win this match and I will do my best but
we'll see we'll see what Wesley can
bring to the table his openings have
been fine
but they haven't inspired confidence and
I think if you're MBL you're sticking to
what you know best night off with black
against E4 grunfeld against D4 and one
E4 with white and Robert I think the
Berlin line with rookie one actually
makes the most sense in bullet because
fighting these small advantages is a lot
harder when you've got 30 seconds on the
clock than when you have let's say a
minute to spend in a critical position
I'm with you and we saw Danny wrench's
question on screen you know if the
players are making drugs because they
each don't think that they are the
favorite in bullets a big question uh
you know it's a kind of a toss-up right
this is bullet chess one plus one we saw
Levon aronian beat Demetri on Drake and
thanks to his great performance in
bullet that was unexpected by Lavon
himself so you never know when it comes
this time patrol all I know is I'm
excited for these games to get underway
I am super pumped speed belts fastened
tight over your waist and Wesley getting
back to his place his internet has held
up nicely so I'm really thankful for
that there would have been nothing more
disappointing than a match marred by bad
internet so good job to the library
keeping their electricity alive during
the snowstorm and Wesley needs some
electricity in these 30 minutes in his
eye that was a good one Donya proud of
you for that and well we'll see if Wes
is able to do just that because he just
had a good position with black he
decided to keep it safe make a draw now
with the white pieces will we continue
seeing the lines we've seen in the
Sicilian uh will Maxime go to be playing
the petrol up which received from him as
well but right now it's all about the
nerves which player can keep their
composure
which player can keep their composure is
the right question to ask what openings
are we going to see mvl has stopped
snacking you don't got a single second
to spare
here we go ladies and gentlemen this is
going to be awesome I mean the bullet
segments Robert in the SEC have just all
been amazing even the Magnus match
because there the question was can
Magnus go lossless here of course the
question is can Wesley pull off yet
another vintage SCC comeback and here we
go
whoa and will we get E4 no we get a no
English Wesley's the first one to
deliver a surprise and he said I don't
you know I don't want all this stuff
we've seen I want you to have to think
from the very early stages
yeah change the record right just change
the nature of the position get something
fresh and we'll see this is an
interesting choice but mvl seems pretty
well prepared against the symmetrical
English in an odd position we have
already if you take on D5 a black can
just take back it's a bishop G2 it's
kind of like a Catalan right now I don't
like that move I was gonna say I think
black can successfully take because with
the bishop on D2 in particular and the D
file control for black I don't believe
in the pawn sacrifice and black can even
cling to the pawn with Queen A6 which I
actually think he should Wesley just
might have forgotten that DC is
available mvl investing some time and he
says hey I'm gonna give back the pawn
but you're gonna have to give me a Tempo
move with my light scored Bishop this is
a good bullet move yes Bishop E6 very
quickly played by maxing Queen H4 there
would be H6 and the queen would be
offside so they're dropping back to E2
but white certainly does not have an
advantage here and black has a bunch of
easy moves he could rattle off Rook ACA
Rook fd8 H6 maybe not the best move but
it's fine and white is still very
cramped and he's now down 15 seconds on
the clock
yes that's not good news for Wesley but
right now Maxine has Rook a to d8 at
some point A3 Knight A4 played instead
and what's the problem here why is the
suddenly better for Black Knight C5 I
think was Wesley's idea and now Bishop
G4 could be real unpleasant that
threatens E4 he plays it immediately an
MBO unraveling a big initiative here
right 96 this he takes F3 Intermezzo
then you take on e61 a piece if the
Knight moves Bishop G4 as you mentioned
looks very annoying oh he's got to give
a pawn up Bishop G4 E4 B7 both loses
Bishop D5 just playing strategic chess
wow this is an amazing positional
decision a bullet game B6 and here come
take my blood give me that e-file uh oh
is it dry if Queen V2 just Rook a b one
Rook back to A1 oh my God Queen A5 B4
traps the queen so MPL evacuates it back
to E8 but now the Knight starts getting
real active yeah Knight C7 just annoying
YouTube doesn't threaten all that much
Rook C7 available as well it goes Knight
B4 he was the C6 Square he's gonna
occupy it and NBL has to take it and now
the Rook takes its place but look at
that Knight on D5 and monster and E4 E3
has to be watched watched very carefully
by Wesley it's played well watch out
because you might be walking to some
kind of pin 93 Rook C3 back oh and the
queen is in trouble
well you can go back to D5 worst case
scenario but I think Wesley's probably
happy with an end game in a past Pawn
right because if you can get this B6
Pawn even if it costs your D4 Pawn you
have to oh gosh this is a pin now
Wesley getting the upper hand he's out
playing him yeah move it to D3 and
Bishop takes D5 was the threat so he
goes Knight E7 and A4 played if this
king gets a bit Rook F7 there was King
E8 and I guess he couldn't defend E4
okay wow what recognition Bishop C6
coming
that was nasty Robert there was Rook B8
missed by Wesley that would have won the
B6 spawn MPL now still alive he's still
alive
what is
well it's a fortress and it's a draw
whoa
oh man what a Miss by Wesley in game one
I wonder if there's actually a fortress
there because the eval bar started like
swinging up but either way it was very
difficult with mere seconds on the clock
and now it's Maxine playing Bishop B5
check I thought Wesley was white again
well at this point I think maxime's
strategy is evident he's trying to play
solid chess and he's trying to play the
clock Robert there was a moment when
Wesley could have put his Rook on B8
rather than C7 winning the B6 Pawn I
think that was game a big bullet dodged
by MBL in game one and a Toothless
Toothless opening by Maxime in game two
yeah it was a uh Bishop B5 check but it
looks like an alapin Sicilian which is
very difficult for black to get an
advantage in and if you're Maxime even
if you're gonna make a draw maybe some
of these you play out right he'd have a
choice on the other game you're
advancing Bishop takes F6 is available
but this position is very level
it's as equal as it gets there is a pawn
imbalance two on three on the queen side
four on three on the king side but with
the same set of minor pieces on the
board and no weaknesses for either side
this is a pretty lifeless end game but
hey it's a bullet game and we know
anything can happen no matter how
balanced the position that's right and
Rusty wants F6 and he could play because
his Rook protect the E6 Pawn King F7
Pawn to E5 King to E6 be very careful if
you're maxing the bishop on D4 is
actually out of scores I understand as
you're pointing out there's a tactic
available so Knight D5 needs to be
protected wait Knight E3 Rook D6 Knight
D1 is also available
not sure how to evaluate that imbalance
B7 B5 Wesley making a lot more progress
here and he's already slightly better
he's doing a fantastic job of keeping
his composure in this end game but can
he actually break through that's the big
question B4 is definitely something to
consider but I don't like all the points
being traded Knight takes before it
looks like mbl's on the path to making a
draw yeah I was thinking before and
Knight takes E3 let me just leave the 95
play Rook c4's Bishop C5 so no you had
to take and now it should be a draw
definitely Rook D4 but then maybe u5 and
Rook C2 to come you're right and if
black wins both of these pawns Robert
there will be massive winning chances in
a bullet game yeah somehow this isn't as
easy as it first appeared and here comes
the activity starts trading off Rooks
take B4 and now Wesley can play with
zero risk yep and despite the fact that
white is the one with a passer
a passer is completely restrained and
White's piece is a lot less active mvl I
think trying to dislodge The Rook from
B2 three and start pushing his B Pawn
it's getting sharp it is indeed and King
G4 to F3 or qe4 now you gotta bring the
king in you have to take a little bit of
risk
and Wesley and he does and he does rook
chak and king D3 and King F3 King F3
yeah he goes King D3 dead that way
there's no Rook C2 no offer of a trade
it saves the tempo and here comes the
e-pawn black is winning black is winning
if he can keep his pawns alive but MBL
is going to go around and start taking
stuff and king or maybe
five okay I think this is right you just
push E3 and then you try to build a
bridge and get the pawn through he goes
Rook did no checks for you then E3 E2 E1
you're gonna have to give me a rook and
I think the black king is so close well
Rook F5 no that's over that's a bad move
that was just obviously losing right
Rook T3 rookie three and Wesley will win
the second game wait but there's rookie
oh still not over
maybe promote just below
here if you're Wesley
and he sees it
and just bring your king up that's it
or is it six oh oh oh he's just yeah The
Rook stop the king side pawns and the
King stops the beep on good
apportionment of Labor by Wesley there
and it is a one point match uh resigned
he could have uh milked some more clock
but he's actually not really in the lead
he's nervous so why waste time he's
trying to play good bullet and Wesley
doing what he does best he gets these
equal end games and he's squeezing them
and mvl just seems less comfortable in
those equal positions than his opponent
this is a pivotal game Wesley will tie
it with a win whoa and where are the
lights oh my gosh I hope the snowstorm
is okay there in Minnesota though the
lights just went out but the lights are
actually shining in his terms of his
chances in this match what is this queen
on C1 doing there Knight D2 as you
mentioned Bishop E2 I like white center
bad play by mvl in the opening to give
up his grunfeld bishop and give white
superiority in the center already a
slight and stable Advantage for Wesley
good move though see 5 can test the
center if you're mvl don't let Wesley
get everything he wants here no but Rook
D1 there is a problem down the D5 at CD4
rookie for here Queen B2 is possible as
well Queen out of six I guess Knight H3
95 I was thinking about and there it is
Bishop 297. no Wesley's on a roll right
now you could just tell it's it's Play
It's pulsating with confidence and
Knight D7 is a dangerous Intermezzo
Robert what do you do you have to go
back wow great move by Max Team honestly
I didn't even think about that move
because there's so many tactics so many
pieces hanging but a really excellent
decision by Maxine and now he can go
Bishop C6 redeploying his bishop and
protecting the Knight look at his clock
though he is now experiencing massive
problems with this clock down 20 seconds
in a bullet game I need to count E4 but
E5 but D5 lots to figure out here for
Maxime uh you can also take on D5 by
Knight C3 if you're Western getting out
of this annoying pin on the F6 B2
diagonal there and he does just that but
Rook F to d8 I thought holds things
together from like maybe it's time for
E4 Oh I thought he had DC and Rook D4
that was actually a little bit clever
instead he allows the trade and it looks
like mvl has solved his problems after
Bishop C6 Rook F4 Queen E5 very
important otherwise the discovery would
have followed no and so we're just
getting trades everywhere and uh this
doesn't look at all problematic for
black and for white I think actually
there are some long-term changes because
a knight versus Bishop end game without
Elder pieces could give some chances but
we'll see if Wesley can make endgame
magic once again
you might remember that they did have
this exact material imbalance in a Blitz
game that game ended in a draw can mvl
squeeze this one out to the full point
uh oh Queen H2 F5 oh my God Queen D2
covering the f4s
oh and every MBL hesitates and he allows
the queen to get to G5 and that can be
scary H4 dropped the King goes to G3 now
oh but Queen C1 hits the Knight is it a
Perpetual is it a Perpetual take over
five he jumps second Pawn oh my God you
have to go to E6 it's still not over
though the king is still dangerous the
king can just go to G3 and there it is
finally oh my God Wesley should win this
now yes he should unreal here goes his
h-bond now Knight 64th oh there's queen
of four check that was clever
and he stabilizes with Queen E3 Wesley
making progress winning another Pawn
here he goes no this is bad news for
Maxime everything going wrong for him
hanging out the king now make threats
where is it Knight F4 Queen D4 Knight D3
oh it goes E5 tonight
pushing the pawn forward but can that
pawn actually promote Queen G3 Queen A7
oh I missed that Queen B8 no he goes
back and through to G7 wait don't hold
Queen D4 there might be a three-time
repetition oh
oh barely oh that was so close
it's still totally winning whoa he wants
the G6 Pawn
but Maxime is somehow holding things
together and he's gonna win E7 wow but
if you trade there's drawing chances
because the B A2 and B3 pawns are in
light squares oh my lands the king is
escaping to E8 but Knight F6 king da
there's no Forks oh my gosh your knight
has to leave the F6 Square that's
terrible news for what's Knight D5 check
would have been immediately a draw so
Queen F4 now or queen F2 it's almost a
three it's almost a three result game oh
my God there's made threats on Queen A1
oh and he plays it
gg5 holy smokes here comes the other
Pawn black spawn with the trade you need
to play Bishop takes Pawn for black it's
what you absolutely must do oh my gosh
careful now careful now don't get mated
and look three seconds for Wesley Queen
before Queen A5 or use Queen C5 instead
no checks for the black queen it is a
draw objectively but Wesley needs to try
to get him forward and he does King G6
no more checks Maxine backpedaling here
trying to keep white at Bay
and it's so difficult to assess this
position
Queen Bishop E8 okay King G7 no more
shags could get fate oh big king of fake
G6 you can push you can push he's he
does us no chance oh my gosh
not over yet wow because you've traded
maybe not
take it and King no it's a joke
King E8 King E8 to your feet now
oh he should have gone the other way oh
but it still might be a draw there's no
way to kick that Bishop out is there
this is no way King G6 Robert but not
King E6 because that allows a fork on G5
right there's no way to get this bishop
out of here and if you're no way you're
just moving around but maybe just
promote and save some time no way yeah
you gotta come to terms of the fact that
there's no win here what a save by
Maxime
unbelievable game
and this is why Knights are so bad is
they can't lose a Tempo and I could lose
a Tempo no the Knight loses the tempo at
some point you're just winning right
yeah if you're gonna do zuke's vong
you'll Force the black king to move into
a forkable square yeah or if you're
Knight's an E8 in the Kings and G6 and
you pass the turn then a great point
right you just need something like that
it's not available that is a draw what a
save from Maxine fascular but Donya it
seems like it's been all Wesley in the
bullet this far it has absolutely and
the good news for Wesley guess what it's
still a one-point match Maxime doesn't
get .75 of a point just because he had a
good save it's still within one and
Wesley still ties the match with a
victory in this game and callers Robert
they don't matter in bullet it doesn't
matter who's white and who's black who's
got the opening Advantage it's all about
Comfort levels can you get a type of
position that you're comfortable with
and we previously saw Maxine with the
black pieces in this line right and that
was when Wesley he didn't take on B5
twice and puts on a D5 so we'll see what
happens this one good play Rook F to see
it it's very important use you bring our
Rook a to C8 but we need both of our
Rooks in the queen side A6 B5 is a
typical plan here though they're you
know you want to watch out for your dark
squares Queen d8 and sometimes you play
Pawn to H6 King to H7 You Queen to h8
for black it looks very weird but it
lines up your bishop and Queen on that
really long diagonal and Maxime invites
that move with Bishop G5 as he Parks his
Bishop on the side of the board to put
some pressure on the Knight he moves the
night away and the Knight traveling over
to C5 or maybe to E5 and you could lose
the C4 Pawn here watch out wait
G5 Intermezzo he missed that this is bad
news from Mexico he's just down to pawn
but he did what Wesley did right in the
games H4 yep your king-site Pawn
structure overextended let's chisel
hammer away go off to the black king but
a great defensive move by Wesley as he
opens up the queen and a pathway between
the queen and the G5 Pawn but that
weakens the D6 spawn and here comes
mvl's Knight whoa Ace is giving up C4 an
ab5 the D6 will be hanging but A2 is
hanging as well you can only take one
Pawn at a time I think this might fizzle
out into some sort of equal position
let's see GH4 to take on D6 he takes an
A2 first
she probably should be thrown in I think
Queen takes G5 perhaps offering a queen
trade watch the back rank H4 also
functioned as a Luft move okay HG Quincy
one check defends that pawn and then
Rook takes B2 there's Queen E8 check
whoa you go he wants queen C1
how do you stop that d8 I think you have
to run I think you have to run with King
H3 you better put on his Nikes and get
out of there there he goes he just did
his Air Jordans are on Queen H1 King
James H5 the king continues to Razzle
dazzles with F3 it looks like oh my good
he takes G2 this is scary Meandering and
bucking and dodging and trying to find
the path to safety is the white king but
Queen takes E4 is a massive threat and
Black's King Robert with that H7 square
is so safe and that was a big blunder
there's Rook H1 oh he's H5 First Take
Queen through his mate here come the
pawns where is the end of this game
rookie one take any four oh goes Queen
F1 even better incredible Queen E2
rookie two there's a million threats and
the queen side Robert is so much less
safe than the king side was because of
the possibility of losing your queen on
B7 Rook C1 and we're in C4 oh Queen C4
okay one mate good call that's it no the
king runs to B6 it's still not over
Queen C5 let's wait oh my God
be two oh and you win the queen he
doesn't see it though he's got three
seconds he goes here he's gonna take a
B2 anyway if King A5 Rook a one then
take up I mean I think you should try
Queen okay three one
gosh this is insane Rook c465. oh that
was winning and this if the Rook was his
Bishop fa checks you have to be very
careful
that's crushing Queen B6 and be all
running out of time
oh he was a queen he's got him he's got
him finally wow
and did you see Wesley pre-moving at
some moments there too oh full Bishop D6
is made oh and he finally checkmates the
white king it took a heroic 30 move
effort and back and forth the king went
and MBL he's let the lead slip Wesley
has tied the match and now we're getting
you know sort of groomed out without
Queens this is known to be a little
something here for white Wesley trying
to play risk-free bullet and he must be
feeling it right now he has taken two
games off of Maxine there is no longer a
leader in this match Wesley is not
thinking about overtime right now he is
thinking about winning this match about
carrying this forward right now it all
comes down to this game and Wesley
Robert look at what he's doing he's
getting exactly the types of positions
he wants equal end games but he's so
good at squeezing them out Magna Style
oh my gosh and look at this position
it's just slightly worse than F5 a
committal choice this Knight can come
back to D2 and into C4 at some moment uh
Bishop D3 is very simple of fe4 we can
just start trading some pieces and some
of these light squares that are in the
long term Imagine a King going to D3 and
C4 if flight score bishops get traded
yeah and you have to imagine these
things because in an end game it's not
just about calculation it's about
long-term thinking as well that's right
G3 by the way there it goes Rook G1 Jeep
Grand G4 let's open up the G5 go up to
the G6 Pawn Wesley is absolutely feeling
it right now every move has so much
energy so much I so many ideas being
displayed Rook F3 Rook F3 oh or this or
first
even better wow big oversight and now
Rook F3 oh and here he comes one Brook
Falls so does whites that is a big Miss
and a big fine from maxiva Shirley Grove
Viva La France he says give me your
pawns one to zero in this game he's just
scored a big goal and Wesley down two
pawns he can't even win a pawn back and
Knight D2 so Rook takes C3 Knight takes
E4 and all of a sudden the G8 Rook is
hangs a rook G4 here takes the Knight if
you take the Rook on G8 great point
oh 96 but then the Rook moves away
oh my God and all of the miners would
have been hanging this is crazy
and A4 was hanging you could have just
taken a pawn over there he said I don't
like this this has to be winning for
black
I mean you have to try to win the G4
Pawn white harnessing his Bishop pair
but the bishop pair isn't enough Knight
f694 and it's over winning a piece game
over you should resign if you're Wesley
immediately 10 45 left in the match and
he's back on his back foot
still plenty of time for Wesley you can
even draw a few games as long as you
stay within that one point Striking
Distance and can get a final game up but
right now back to the Sicilian Dania
he's played it quite well from the black
side instead of Bishop C4 which Maxine
did in an earlier game in Blitz now that
was Bishop G5 line and VL has the white
pieces he really needs to try to win
this one I don't think he should go
conservative try to make a close draw
that's not his style even though I think
Wesley's fine with the repetition and
evil shouldn't repeat yeah why not just
play castle play on there's no risk at
the moment 92 Allah gotta komski I feel
like I'm watching him just maneuver his
pieces over the C4 Square
got a big proponent of the early A4
Knight off lines with white and mvl
preparing Bishop F1 and freeing up the
Knight for action on the king side and
Bishop F3 that's not much of a bishop at
the moment but it does protect E4 Knight
e3 coming D5 F5 if you ever take a
knight and F5 that Bishop F3 will be
superb he's playing this like a good
old-fashioned Soviet school boy but I
love Queen C6 prevent 94 3 and aim at
the E4 pawn and Robert d65 can change
the landscape of the position
immediately
yeah in Bishop F5 now taking D5 that's
what I thought oh the E5 was hanging
there so that's probably four first oh
good call E4 first then D5 expand your
Center he plays Bishop of Fate I don't
mind the move so much uh now you can't
take on that five or can you with E4 to
follow well you can absolutely can and
the bishop has no good squares and then
T5 C4 steamrolling white in the center
but he missed it what is B5 it
sacrifices a pawn but I guess E4 is
loose in some positions and it's not the
first time he's misplaced the the pawn
move B5 mvl says gimme gimme gimme
Jimmy Garoppolo and that looks pretty
good for white this looks pretty bad if
you ask me for black so oh my God that
was amazing
Knight C7 with a fork uh D5 hanging
Brooklyn a bishop on E6 glad we get some
49ers references in there real quick
no the stream would be complete at least
the Steph Curry reference I have not
made a Steph Curry reference today this
match has been too mesmerizing and
Maxime trying to Curry some favor with
the chess gods playing a nice little
night orphan he stands better he's up
upon this is danger time for Wesley but
watch over D3 not anymore because uh
there's no Fork but Knight A4 hits beat
to and C2 at the same time he goes back
instead of four but no he's on a yo-yo
string Knight A6 back to him B2 is
hanging Rook C2 to follow D4 is loose as
well
okay so black is DuPont's down but he's
gonna win the pawn back end Robert it's
a three result game I mean White's
pieces are really loose here
but it looks good for MBL don't go F4
okay
and Bishop H5 wins the piece Bishop H5
it's over from all directions and that
wait we're seeing with me
and that's what he missed and that's
what he missed Knight C4 keeps trying
but a quick resignation from Wesley he's
still a segments of 40 seconds if he
wins this game I also forgot the knights
move backwards and cover up the back
rank oh Wesley going back to this
English and Maxime he's playing this
kind of like a slav
and this is the must win game for Wesley
he should be solid he is he can make a
draw there's enough time for two more
games we remind you that if there's any
time left on the match clock the game
can begin even if there's two seconds
left so there is time enough for three
or four more games
that is indeed the case the B5 square
into white control the B4 Square not
really so much under blacks to the
bishop on D2 white ahead and development
some weak squares on the queen said
Knight E5 jumping in there Knight B5 as
you're pointing out as well the A6
Knight a little bit loose and
uncomfortable I like this for Wesley
yeah not mvl style at all very surprised
with the choice of a slave which she
really doesn't play playing right into
Wesley's heads you can tell he's
uncomfortable he goes back and forth
yo-yoing between B4 and A6 this ain't
good no it's not Knight C6 if you take
the second row come to C1 Queen comes up
Knight back to East Rook C2 Rook C1 just
double on the C file only open file whoa
Knight A3 goes the night Bishop takes A5
is a nasty little hidden threat oh I
didn't even see that I thought he just
want to stop Rook C8 but you're right
Bishop A5 he takes it and queen B7 to
follow
but Knight ac5 is going to be super
nasty watch that B3 square there's a
potential fork in there good call I
think we have to use D E Knight C5 Queen
B5 Rook B8 and Rook takes C5 give up
your queen for a pawn a knight and a
rook and get that Alaska compensation
although Robert in my experience Queen
down positions and bullet are super
dangerous he decides to take a six okay
I like you buy a thread here Bishop H2
can get you Queen D6 check picks up the
bishop on A6 but after King G1 I think
the end game would be better for whites
it was Rook B8 instead and you could
think about de5 well are we gonna get a
repetition also Queen A7 or K8 and at
this point Envy I'll obviously fine with
a draw Wesley weighing the pros and cons
he might have to take it he goes Queen
A7 because Queen makes music he does
have enough time you mentioned this he
can make a draw here get a couple boys
he was Queen C6 he says play on but
Brook
bc5 you have to this is the one time I
don't really like the decision to play
on I feel like black is squarely better
in this position but I respect the risk
Knight F2 he's bonded upon he's
blundered this Pawn here
he's better on the queen side but he's
dropping pawns all over the place and
that's not going to be sufficient the A5
Pawn takes care of two white pawns and
his Wesley's only chance might be to try
to get before and create a creative
Pastor look at the clock also he needs a
miracle he needs a miracle in this game
Rook D1 rookie Rook C3 watch out oh
Knight B2 there I guess you're taking E3
D1 the uh the E7 Hanks he's done it okay
let's see how this goes but Robert after
rookie seven the Knight comes back to B2
and you lose A4 as well ah Rook A7 you'd
lose it and he's no no no no no
wait a second he needs to win this game
instantly and win another you know he
doesn't have enough time I don't think
he's got enough time and mvl can just
milk three minutes off the clock and
Wesley playing a French against the
Frenchman I don't know how I feel about
that now if you're mvl this game should
last as long as possible Robert we have
even seen bullet games take four and a
half minutes this game alone could wipe
the rest of the time off the match clock
yeah and this is the position where for
Maxine with the white pieces oh no this
just looks really not good for women
total collapse total collapse for Wesley
in this game yeah and he's not even
gonna take the Rook he's just gonna
Checkmate him that's just mean unless
he's a nice guy everybody knows it you
don't gotta do it no Queen G3 and H5 and
it's the wheels have come off completely
here yeah let's go King F7 and if H5
Rook GA and just pray but unfortunately
for Wesley it's uh not going to be his
day but Maxine H5 he wasn't selected by
the masses he was a 30 pick in this one
he defeated Jana pomsey the world chess
champion Challenger he then is going on
to beat Wesley so the former Fisher
random world champion the global
champion and Maxine vashilagov not to be
stopped at least not by Wesley he's
gonna face Magnus Carlson an epic
rematch of 2020. somewhere in a deep
dark corner in a nondescript building
smarter chess poured himself a nice
expensive glass of Bordeaux wine he's
sipping it he's enjoying it and he's
telling the audience well you know who
to trust now
he may not have uh found the right Point
totals from each tie Patrol but in the
end it doesn't even matter because
Maxine vashilagrove is getting it done
just when Wesley so stormed back tied
the match Maxime with that mental
fortitude that experience it pays off
here Bishop takes H3 go for it it's
bullet you won the match already let's
have some fun
I know the chat is keeping their fingers
crossed because I haven't made any
sports references yet today at least not
that many but I will break the streak
now Robert we see this often in sports
games especially in basketball when you
make a big comeback and then the
opposing team makes another push right
you tie the score and then you're losing
again oftentimes you just lose your
heart you're like man I just did all
this work to Ty and I've got to come
back again and that's kind of what we
saw here not taking anything away from
Maxime of course right now Maxime has
been he you know the five plus one he
was just downright impressive and the
three plus one he looked a bit shaky to
start the bullet he looks lost and then
suddenly he found it within himself to
fight back the claw he was actually you
could see distressed his emotional state
was clear as day to everybody and now he
has won I think four games in a row
right it was tied 11-11
yeah and you could just see the
relaxation I mean the muscles relaxing
here and MBL knows the match is in the
bag whether this is the last game or not
he has actually the largest lead of the
entire match at this point taking rookie
three
oh
and he missed Rook either Queen B2 is
very good A3 is hanging and B4 next
there might be a
125. oh you saw that so quickly I'm
looking for all those Forks there it is
tickle collapse stick a fork in Wesley
his SCC run has come to a conclusion
it's unfortunate because Wesley is so
strong I mean obviously he won the
global championship and Magnus was
himself yesterday said how impressive
that was but for Wesley he just found
himself in a hole and even when he dug
out of it it still wasn't quite enough
because Maxim just as it looked like it
was turning away from him he really just
was able to win that critical game and
thus win the match and it was such a
great match to win Wesley should hold
his head up high I mean he played great
he was a little bit off right he was a
little off in that five minute segment
and I think that early deficit it wore
him down and at the end of the day it
could have been anyone's match if Wesley
won that pivotal game we would have been
singing very likely a totally different
tune but mvl is a beast in this format
he really is and there's a reason he was
able to beat Magnus Carlson I can't name
anybody else in the planet who has done
that so uh Magnus and Maxime they will
have a rematch 30 seconds left in this
one we may get one fun game let's say
like bomb Cloud let's see it here it
comes Queen H5 Queen H5 Oh I thought
we're gonna get a bomb cloud
they're playing the opposite they're
playing like the most serious like this
screams GM chess line ever exchange Caro
and with Queen B6 let's swap Queens off
the board uh the pawn B6 can become a
Target so you have to be careful about
this if we're just speaking in terms of
chess strategy uh but I think right now
Wesley so he's probably not thinking
much about the chess he's kind of like
Ugh this match got away from me you know
he fought back so validly uh but it was
a little bit short in the end
it was and perhaps the change of uh
surroundings playing from a library due
to a snowstorm in Minnesota I'm sure
that didn't help it does look like
Wesley's all right like the internet was
working and at the end of the day
this was just a classic barn burner
Rubber and we have we've had so many of
these in the SEC thus far and we know
Wesley he doesn't make excuses right the
fact that he had to go to library to
compete he's not going to use that as
the reason he lost him he tied the match
it was even with just about 10 minutes
to go and then Maxine won that game and
has never looked back so right now
they're still playing this last one good
on them and then just make a draw I
think nope uh for uh Wesley here he's
just making decent moves improving his
position and the two Bishops should be a
little bit better
yeah I mean we remind you that there is
a part of the prize pool that is divided
based on win percentage so there might
actually be like two or three hundred
dollars on the line in this game alone
and you know for these players for
people like Wesley he takes every single
game seriously he gives it his all even
though the match has been decided and
that's what we're looking for when we
watch online chess matches
and credit to him because you know when
he was down four points at some point I
think it was looking really bad he could
have just become dejected and thrown in
the towel but he has fought the entire
win 1983 doesn't work Rook F2 at the end
Rook it through to start
hello trying to end with a flourish but
instead Wesley gonna make it a cosmetic
difference in score the match has been
decided and Bishop takes G5 should end
it yeah just go for the attack not the
material he takes on D4 he can take an
A3 next so uh he does get material
anyway and for Maxine he's still a smile
on his face this last game
yeah he already won the match the smile
of someone who knows that this game does
not truly matter he is going to resign
it and again a purely cosmetic
difference Maxime has won by four points
and he is a bracket Buster because only
30 percent of people who predicted this
match and they're only 15 of all
brackets submitted have this is a
matchup Maxima Shirley Grove you know
he's got this little smile on his face
when you look at the scoreboard it does
all the Talking six and a half four and
up I think there's actually the smarter
chess prediction for the bullet
yeah good day for Team France I think
they're still beating Morocco Mexico
beating Wesley they won so Viva La
France and Maxima shiligrav another
Stellar performances he knocks off one
of the SEC stalards dealing him the
first ever loss against someone not
named hn or MC that's right and well you
had an MC Hammer reference and uh this
one it's been all fun but right now
we're gonna take a break and get Maxine
vashir lagrov in on the call for a
post-match interview but before we do I
want to remind everybody put your
questions in the chat we may feature
them we'd love to ask Maxime the good
questions that you asked so please go do
that right now while we go on a short
break and bring the winner of the smash
into the call for the post-match
interview you'll hear from Maxime Russia
lagrav in just a few
foreign
stars on all of your favorite platforms
just search chess.com and your favorite
chest star on Discord Twitter WhatsApp
and more to find hundreds of gifts from
chess.com's biggest broadcast and events
Hikaru Magnus botes Hess and even me
Danny try it today
thank you
[Music]
foreign
by the Frenchman with three names that
is Maxine vasher lagrav he defeats
Wesley so congratulations Maxime that
was a tremendous performance my first
question for you is the opening choices
you were as diverse as I've ever seen
you with your repertoire
yeah it was a plan to sort of experiment
especially with black
I had a few ideas on what to do
especially in the patchwork uh even one
for
uh for Accelerated dragon in one game
and then went to a solimo but
yeah I just felt in good shape and
um well but obviously today was only I
mean this match was not the uh you know
biggest factor for French fans
because at the same time
while we're qualified to finance so
we'll definitely ask you your thoughts
about that a little bit later but
Maxim you held a lead for most of this
match and then in the bullet it seemed
like the first half of the bullet was
all Wesley and then when the match was
tied you flipped a switch did you make
any conscious changes to your approach
to the bullet or do you feel like you
just played the same way and things
started to go your way once the match
was tied
yeah I feel like for a while first
followers I was playing incredibly well
and keto swim too for putting up such a
fight because well means it is playing
conditions and stuck in the library I
mean must not have been easy but
um so yeah first half of the bullet I
mean Not only was Wesley playing strong
but also I couldn't find
my game I couldn't play my moves freely
probably because I also kind of I didn't
have time to to play bullet these days
like compared to my match with uh nepo I
had been practicing bullets quite a lot
and well
some uh
I lost you lose fast this ability but
then whenever I found a way to to free
up my moves I think of course turning
points was when I got back to press one
I think with some tactics and then
suddenly I was playing much
much more liberated
yeah I think that's a good word for it
because you're placing very free
throughout the match and well when you
jumped out to this big lead in the five
plus one how did you kind of just keep
yourself composed I know it's early
stages but with a big lead sometimes I
think players May slip a bit but uh you
know how did you kind of maintain your
just chest focus at that moment
yeah exactly I was actually playing
really quite well in the first
section and I add a couple of Lucky
breaks of course this Berlin and game
which somehow ended up in my favor
uh with this uh ended up with two points
against two queens but uh
yeah this was a bit of Madness and then
I kind of let twister back into the
match especially with the next game this
special for uh
some some nice tactics but of course
then later on I I saw that I had this
bishop texter for check when text F6
that would have Saves the Day
and
because I was just pulling up actually
for most of the games so I thought like
maybe I make it to plus five and then
essentially I I don't think you're gonna
come back from that
um and somehow yeah then things uh were
not as smooth so I started doubting
myself because for
for the first hour I was just playing
matches
maximum I have a bit of an odd question
when you prepare for players of your
level and this is a question both about
Blitz and also classical do you think in
terms of strengths and weaknesses like I
want to get these types of positions or
do you feel that everybody by this point
is so Universal that the Crux of your
preparation is still just openings
Well everybody's kind of universal
that's for sure
um and let's say you obviously want in
the opening to play the strongest moves
and but of course
okay first of all in Blitz you know some
instincts of the players you know
um
uh come back and also I feel like you
know because now most of the time in the
opening you're not really looking for an
advantage
so my thinking is which line should I
play against which open and because
maybe they are trouble with that line in
the past maybe because I feel like they
don't want to keep tension or on the
contrary they want to keep tension so
then I will play something a little bit
more dull and yeah so of course you know
choices uh very depending on on your
opponent even on at this level because
we still have like definite uh yeah
strengths let's say we have
like no real weakness I mean or maybe
weaknesses compared to that level
um but of course all of us have this
kind of you know
uh big strands that we're trying to use
well yeah you're matching big strength
so I have to ask you did you watch the
chess boxing event at all that happened
the other day
yeah I mean I shouldn't have watched
because uh then I was playing an online
tournament at 9 00 am
and I ended up staying up until five or
something
so I watched most of the
most of the thing I mean I I had enough
just before and as a chessboxing even
started so that was all right
and uh yeah it was actually quite
impressed especially with Aman I must
say uh I didn't think he would get his
boxing game so high up
and of course with Andrea in the boxing
she was
maniac
foreign
I'm not going to ask you whether you're
going to be watching France versus
Argentina that would be a dumb question
instead I'm going to ask you what your
style of watching is when there are
these important matches do you usually
watch them at home alone or do you like
to go with friends
I think for one thing like a at least
it's not clashing with any of the
speeches
so this time I'm gonna be watching for
sure
yeah
and let's say of course I want France to
win
uh but at the same time if Argentina
wins and Messi gets uh you know his
first World Cup
uh I wouldn't mind like let's say
against any other team uh then friends I
would have voted for Argentina
yeah it's fair uh big messy fans around
the world but last question I have for
you is actually about Chess and about
the SEC you next play Magnus Carlson in
the semi-finals you of course famously
defeated him a couple years ago how are
you feeling heading into that matchup
against the world champion who remains
the world champion for now until he
gives up his title
but I saw his performance yesterday so
uh well
first thing is not to get adopted
this
this I wouldn't mind very much and of
course if I play like consistently the
way I played in the first like
half of this match against West Side I
might have some chances like uh I know
that
uh with my style of play and you know
sometimes I find some tactics that
Magnus doesn't find
also one is in good shape it's it's
tough to actually out train even in that
area so you know we'll see obviously it
comes as a big favorite and if he puts
up a performance like he did against
Fabi
um it will be very tough but no matter
which kind of Magnus comes up uh on
Friday yeah I mean uh I will be ready
for a big fight and you know uh play my
my chances are as best as I can
fantastic well Maxine that was very
insightful we'll be watching your match
against Magnus very closely and with a
lot of enthusiasm good luck in that
tough match and good luck to friends
thank you
thanks Maxime
off to have a wonderful rest of his
evening he sent Wesley so goodbye in
this event he won 16 and a half 12 and a
half and he moves on to face Magnus
Carlson and something I've always you
know appreciative about Maxine is so
humble right he just was like oh I'll
have a chance against Magnus he beat
Magnus in this exact format a couple
years ago and he's making it seem like
oh maybe if I'm fortunate you know I can
hang in there with him he beat Magnus
head to head just two years ago
yeah he did and there's nothing that
gives you more confidence than having
done it already it's like with
Grandmaster Norms with anything in chess
when you when you've done it already you
know it's possible you know under the
right set of circumstances it can happen
again and Magnus knows that as well but
Maxime has his priorities in order
priority number one is don't get adopted
and as he himself admitted if Magnus
plays the same level that he played
against Fabby I mean not even Conor
McGregor can stop him from Landing blow
after blow it's going to be a tough
match for maxim it's going to be an epic
match and there's nothing I love more
Robert than seeing an SEC match where
both players are in good form after we
just we're talking about Chess boxing
and you mentioned Conor McGregor I had
to laugh because I visualized for a
second what that would look like in it
Maxine versus McGregor yeah the mashup
of the ends it wasn't a pretty uh Vision
in my head but what is quite a pretty
thing is the final four here in the
speechless Championship look at this
bracket
Nakamura nihal sarin we have Magnus
Carlson and maybe a bit of a surprise
because he was the 11th seed I think he
was underestimated under seated it is
Maxine vashilagrove the reigning world
Blitz champion who has not competed that
much online making his way through to
the semis Dania we are spoiled we are
and I don't remember the name of that
game where you don't know the sentences
but you have to choose the word
categories is it Mad Lib
um where you get sentences and you just
got his name and adjective in the name
of verb and then the sentence is sound
absurd well here you can pick and choose
blindly whatever Hikaru Hall Carlson mvl
whichever matchup you're gonna get in
the finals is going to be absolutely
epic and both of these are going to be
unmissable literally must watch TV and
I'm so glad that it doesn't conflict
with France versus Argentina so you have
a massive lineup of entertainment if
you're a chess and soccer fan you have a
great lineup you have no excuse you
better be here tomorrow when Hikaru
Nakamura takes on nihal sarin that is 6
a.m Pacific time and you will not want
to miss these two absolute Monsters
behemoths of Blitz and bullet Hikaru
Nakamura the reigning Champion uh nehal
sarin the upstart the wonderkin the cgc
runner up to Wesley so he's in the
semi-finals for the second year in a row
he was defeated last year in a close
match against Wesley Sosa we'll see if
he could take down Hikaru Nakamura so
Dania will be having the call for that
tomorrow but before we sign off today
and we round things up I want to remind
everybody of the Collegiate chess League
registration is open for the spring 2023
season of the Collegiate chess league if
you're a university student and want to
represent your school in the best online
chess league for college students sign
up now don't miss your shots to make
history in the biggest CCL season to
date type the command CCL in the chat
for more registration closes on January
13th
Tanya that was a mouthful and what we
just saw was just breathtaking stuff
from Maxine Russell grave he started hot
he sort of fizzled a bit down the middle
of the event and then when it came to
the Finish Line he was able to take the
lead and not let it go so that was
really a fun match and unfortunate for
Wesley so but a great play from Maxine
Russia La Grave listen a four-hour
airplane flight feels like 16 hours a
four hour SCC match technically three
hours of gameplay she will take it lasts
five minutes I feel like I was just
starting to commentate their first five
minute game which Wesley so won but
Maxine Michelle agrav at so many points
in this match he needed to deliver
Wesley was creeping up on him he tied
the match in the bullet but Maxim's
composure his Verve his energy the
energy with which he plays is
mesmerizing to watch and it leads to a
blow for Wesley soas is SCC run comes to
an end yes it does but Maxine versus
Sheila Grove's run continues he will
face Magnus Carlson in the semi-finals
but first is tomorrow's action between
Hikaru Nakamura and nielsarin but for
now on behalf of Grandmaster Daniel
naroditski and myself Grandmaster Robert
Hess we thank you all for watching it's
been an absolute treat to cover this
event for you and we'll see you tomorrow
bright and early for Hikaru Nakamura and
the Elsa on semi-final match
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]